hello
you are the first
under 1500 streamer
leaf work
and others hello
autumn marathon
marcos thank you very much
37 in a row for you
a little surprised
the night retreat
releases pressure here sometimes there's
the saccharonies
oh another thing is if i go here the
bishop has to
doesn't have that fallback square
anymore
on b3
not the only way to hit the bishop i
could go here
i like this though
maybe i sneak in well i mean let's get
one more developing movement
the jetter
91 thank you
for the tier one nine in a row for you
chess brand hello brew blue gracies
thomas carl
surprised to see that move as well
giving up the dark square bishop
might as well a castle
could try to be sneaky
this would be hope chess here castles
bishop g5 wins the queen
but
don't want to give up that big square
i guess i'll castle
sammy what's going on
uh good game sammy from last night
i should pick up the speed here
it is increment
opposite-sized castling
i am not afraid of this push
let's get developed
rook to c8
okay i'm a bit more tempted to play this
move now actually
but maybe before i do that
i should uh
kick the knight from observing this
square
i like this idea let's give the knight a
boot
and then think about uh
challenging this duo
this pawn pushes or captures bishop g5
threat here is to also just take
you know winning the queen now
those of you familiar with the marathons
lance 5500 is almost always a
guy that will
press for
the title he'll be up there and i
believe this is one of the first times
i'm seeing him play
right in the beginning
he did not win the last one
maybe he's really out to
to get the victory this time
all right
i'll i'll play in the center
i like this idea of the queen slipping
in
or even uh you know this move
pinpointing this dark square
tough to defend
yes
in full retreat mode
i am
it's a queen versus a minor piece that
is the
imbalance
i'll take here
maybe that wasn't the
greatest choice
i got an in between i'll take with the
king
in a different scenario if the queens
were still on i felt like if if i felt
my queen would be under some fire
i would uh
i would maybe think about just hiding
behind the pawn
but
these guys are
far away
from
scaring me
i get to take with check
i guess we'll just keep pushing a little
bit
rook is pinned hitting the bishop living
off of the increment as usual
let's just go here get a passer
let's get one rook off
let this guy have some fun
and i'll
take getting there i'm on this point too
all right
it's a cornered knight
we should have a mate and a few
no stalemates
got pawns
all right
electro funk daddy thank you for the
prime sub
hello fresh salsa chips
fort mort
do i play otb
uh it's been a while but yeah i mean i
have i have a
i am a national master so i needed to
play in over the board tournaments
this is a
a category in
the uscf rating system
united states chess federation
has a national master
2200 or above all right let's try
let's try e4
coolio
one two two three thanks for the tier
one
resub 18 in a row now 20 total
let's go knight c3
i'm doing pretty good i'm back from a
high school football game
voice is not worn from the game it
sometimes is from
yelling but it wasn't really much of a
game
so
okay
uh
so
this is drawing my attention
some
quick strike against um
i mean don't i have something soon here
here here
queen f3
threatening mate
knight here and then queen here
threatening mate once again and also
threatening this point
i'm going to try it
boom
oh they missed the mate
all right
this is
elite
one three three seven
ready irrationally selfish
oh i missed one first callus one thank
you for the tier one
resub five months in a row now
uh rationally
selfish thank you for the 100 bits
uh yeah i played a year
[Music]
um and my my high school football
experience is limited i played one year
as a
sophomore no i don't don't have a kid in
high school uh
supporting a
local team
is all
um i'm gonna back off here just kind of
anticipating this
breaking up of my pawn duo
i'd like to
be able to meet
d5 with e5
okay
so i have no no worries of a pin
boom
i'll just duck
team voc
thank you as well
get another smothered mate you said
is that a smothered mate i guess it was
i don't know i normally just have it in
my mind a knight
is the one piece that gives the
smothered mates
all right how do i want to set things up
here
does this pawn want to contribute
maybe tell you what i'm going to go here
because i may want to drift in this
direction i like to keep this pawn
available
in case there's some
some pressure mounted against d4
so this is just a temporary pit stop
otherwise this bishop will
be upset
with this guy
so he's ready to
take a journey like you would see
in the roy lopez
now
i did say i wanted to maybe meet this
move with e5
maybe maybe not i think i'm also
comfortable with simply recapturing at
the night so at least give it a move i
think i'll i'll be basically playing
this no matter what
so
yeah i think it's useful in
in many cases all right so they are
hammering away
at d4
i'm going to say let's just get on with
this now still
so
my knight now boxed out this may be some
some
maneuver bishop here within c4
really trying to solve the problem of a
bad bishop in what is
looking like a french defense now
fee day rating is just about 2200.
right around there
hello jammer
or pangatan
that was a question you had okay so
as mentioned i i think you know if you
really do want to play this you should
probably get this bishop behind enemy
lines right right now it's a
a stuck pawn and
this guy will need to move eventually if
if black is to get this advance in
because i could always stop
stop b4
with a3 so the a pawn is necessary in
order to uh
eventually create a pawn duo
all right well let's get on let's get it
oh i i
i uh deselected that knight
like it dropped out of uh
my mouse unclicked there
anyhow
under a minute
these guys are off to a blistering start
k.a star and valera
i was curious about this player
very high rated
nm
i looked at uh
i looked at their profile
they're a 25
about a 25 50 feed a rated
player
so
uh
this
this is not uh
excuse me this is a deceptive
very deceptive title
i guess they didn't uh
officially get the title or whatever
maybe they don't want it
that's a thing
all right
how do you approach this
i'm going to say let's put this guy here
i could i could have gone here maybe
maybe i should have to observe these
squares yeah that would have made more
sense
yeah i think this is redundant
this pressure this this is rock solid f5
for black i i should have
i should have uh
i should have gone for this are they
gonna lose on time
what's going on really
13 mover
what's going on
all right
just when it was getting interesting
like uh
maybe like a race position
they go queen side i go king's side
all right down on the clock roni
dr leper thank you for the 500 bits
you add thanks jerry for teaching me to
play chess you're welcome
you learned it
you learned it from that video the video
just sharing how to make the moves
vtr for stream
thank you for the twitch prime resub
two months in a row now
all right
this guy is uh not going to contribute
now
i don't have to worry about this where
where's the where's the pawn break
let's get this guy
playing
um thank you to the anonymous
gifter
someone has just uh
anonymously gifted three subs
thank you to whoever you are appreciate
that
and ride a rider
you have
nobody to thank
you have somebody to thank but you just
don't know who
all right
bring in the pain
all right let's
say what are you doing in my house
i don't like that you're on my side
go away all right they were quick to
leave
sometimes you would maybe see that move
okay my queen
was not playing
all right let's continue to develop
here
and how to recapture
i'm gonna say
what's with the pawn
because these guys are happy now this
guy at least
okay
all right so my knight has
does not have e4 anymore
oh you know what i should also have
been careful about if this pawn wasn't
on e2 i'm dead
okay
uh let me go here
i don't know what i want to do with my
king yet
okay well
i was planning on moving my queen and
then some reposition with my knife but i
guess uh
i i guess i'm cool with this i have some
dark squares i could hop into
and here's the other here's another
detail
since i haven't castled kingside i could
consider h6 to activate my rook
and maybe my king will be
quite all right on e8
hmm
i kind of like this idea
prepared to take with the rook
okay let's take
is that too soon
oh they're taking with the rook that's
surprising
i think i went upon now
so this the guy can
move away
back off
let the rooks see the world
control e4
and there's no way to defend upon
this would be quite the active rook from
h4 as well
it's looking like i will well i don't
know if i even want to castle queenside
it seems kind of cozy right here
e7 dark square
okay it's making a run for it no
this is serious
okay defended
castling by hand
yeah i'm not gonna castle
i'll just stay right here i don't even
know if i need to move my king
okay
well i will
just kind of get out of any
anything happening here i feel
a bit more confident
rushing this pawn up now this rook is
unprotected
and now this knight is unprotected
and now this is
this is a problem
crash through right now
got the
got the bishop there
not taking the bishop
why not
all right let's back off this rook is
ready to be hunted now
and the bishop
a lot of ways to do it at this stage
let's start with this let's restrict uh
this rook first
okay
could take that rook
i might as well just take it
how about here
check
let's invade
check
and the queen and pawn will be enough to
do the job
on b2
main main two
group 64. hello
there my opponent resigned
macholid thank you mclead 1986 thank you
for the 500 bits
you add hey jerry do you remember
antoine squared i do
antoine
anton yes i do
uh logically compromised thank you very
much for subscribing hello what is going
on
uh kitty kitty hiss hiss
thank you for gifting a sub
to chessy spaghett and
jesse spyga has gifted a a tier one sub
back to kitty kitty is hiss
ah you guys are awesome
do i have the coffee ready i'm not much
of a coffee drinker
no
i'm not uh i don't do too well with
caffeine
dino you just
successfully
defended your phd thesis
let's get it moving ooh did i almost
lose on time
it turned red
it's in the red there
okay
that's a funny
that's a cool emo eric rosen drinking
tea
that's a good one
all right
we'll try to play like alpha zero
this is the uh
the dark square domination
game we are following
now
right now
before castling
[Music]
all right
all right c6 was not uh
all right let's chop
and now uh
um
let's go here
i have given up a pawn
ooh
i have a check here
so they're okay with uh me grabbing that
bishop
check here
chop
queen here i guess my
my knight is one back but
that can't be good
i mean i could run away
here
oh actually that's not even a move here
here here if the queen goes
here i could play bishop takes knight
because there's a pineroni
all right i think that's a
a blunder
ooh
a resigner
boom
back to tournament
number one and two guy are going at it
right now
look at that
128 124
get him lance
if lance if flying's plays in the whole
thing and out he's
i'd i'd pick lance to win it
just the experience
all right um
all right fiend keto
that's my plan
this night's gonna be here
okay that's
welcome
yes or no yes all right first we chop
we gotta break these guys up
yes
and now we go here i do not want to take
the knight in this case
so i'm following
my
advice here
in that latest video
on youtube
all right so something i like now is
that
my pieces will interact well on the b2
square
just naturally
long diagonal it's now opened b file
let's get my butt castled
a little chest fan one two three
all right
one or two steps
i prefer to just keep this
nice compact
structure
and
this right here actually has my
attention
f5 preparing to recapture with the
bishop
i am subjecting myself to checks
when i play
i don't think that that's really a
problem though would be a problem
hmm
huh
yeah i'm gonna say let's let's play this
right now
a lot of first-time opponents i've been
playing
i think it's pretty common
there are already
i think about three
uh 3 500
competing
to chop or not
i'm gonna say yes
this rook is helped but i will soon be
helped
some development with tempo
and if the rook is not patrolling the
fourth rank i could consider this pin
however
my opponent does have a queen move
with check
to get out of this pin
okay
ignoring the threat i have against the
rook i think that's a good move
because my uh my intended queen d7 could
be met with rook here
don't really like that
um i could also consider this i mean how
much influence will this dark square
bishop have anyhow
i think i maybe like this idea i know
it's a
normally a super important piece to keep
around to defend the weakened squares
around my king but my queen will have a
my queen should be able to fulfill that
role
and there isn't really much uh
i don't know
what you really can't attack
my king i don't see at least all right
let's let's get this rook here
if this
i have to worry about the queen coming
out here
also b3
places a constraint on the rook
and my queen does a good job guarding
the dark squares
offering a queen exchange
so the plan here is after queen takes
knight takes rook takes pawn
let's take this this rook is not it's
not just any pawn i'd be winning
and the other thing is that
hmm well i think this is best i just
ripping the heart out of the queen side
here these are now very weak in my rook
and
my rooks start to
work pretty well on the f2 square so i
saw that there
is that move
bishop here was my idea and i think it's
a good one
could get out of it with chuck
um
still tricky to defend that yeah
i wanted to go here
but then i don't have a thread on f2
anymore so
i think i just uh
go here
now when the knight moves
there is this id to try to win my bishop
i do have a block but this is this is
serious now
okay
um well i could still take that
let me let me take that
i could always drop back
it probably will oh here's the other
thing here
block rook takes king takes knight takes
pawn bishop here
it could be tough to defend this point
um can i go here
takes check check
um
i don't think i got to go faster too
merrick is still very active i think i
have the superior minor piece in this
ending
let us see
i'm going to throw in a checkeroni
let's go here now
knight is a bit short on squares
i have to go with the check and then
block
hey
oh boy
we got some windmill action
just a little windmill action
actually forget about the
forget about the windmill we got matin
it's a main three
i go here and the rook has to block and
i take for me
they needed to play rook off too
you know they resigned here
i get to pick my favorite square
here here is mate
there was still resistance there for
sure
it was going to be an equal material
ending bishop versus knight
thank you to
butter emails for the prime sub
and also to dr dre mate
for the raid
the delayed
queen rook pawn attack
watch out for that
[Music]
mystic knight
doing the old three-stepper
all right
let's get on with development
let's just pretend like this pond is
not doing
much at all
and be a castler
be a developer
i get the impression they're gonna
launch queenside pawn here
all right let's see if my c pawn could
do something dangerous
all right this is also
player you don't want to get into a time
scramble with let's do it
no development
let's open up lines
for my developed pieces
squares maybe i get this one
i got this one already
maybe i get an open e file
okay
moving that bishop again
i'll go with the queen
it feels weird just going one step with
the bishop probably wants to uh
as sarawan would say eyeball
i could oh i could have captured this
pawn
probably wants to eyeball this weak
square
all right so i had an opportunity last
move to take here
and i still have that option
why am i not taking
it
i just i don't even want it i don't know
if i want it
yeah i want it
another
sarawan line be a pawn grabber
all right
i'm up a pawn this rook is brought to
life
and
how to defend the knight
i'll go here
pinkado
okay
all right i'll take
uh i mean i could get another pawn why
not
opponents giving me pawns let's take
them all
fly back to d4
yes
um can i go here
bishop takes pawn can i take advantage
of that pin
yeah
i don't mind giving this square up to
black
i want to be able to move this rook
all right where's the knight going
let's go here
i want to play this to hit the rook
but i don't want my bishop behind that
pawn
now we do this
threatening some
some dangerous stuff on g6
[Music]
boom boom
boom block
check
the rook and block
let's do this instead
full rook
i want my queen here instead of my
bishop
well that's helpful
that's very helpful
and we got mate next
it's mate next move
all right mystic knight
wasn't developing
i don't feel like i'm playing well
uh
winning games but
still playing this guy'll smack me
around
kazak fighter surprise we haven't
already played
20 2800
in the bullet category
yeah i've seen his
some of his games before
we got a french defense
huh
don't see that one too often
bishop there
let me do something
different
okay
if i go here
i don't know let's just make moves
okay
now that okay
[Music]
let's go here
yes
and this move will be challenged
i want to get to this square i don't
want to commit my knight to the queen
side
he's
he's nearing that position
let's take a step oh this is also a nice
square as well
all right
i don't know where i want to go with my
king oh okay
my opponent is heading for
one of these two squares
can i castle kingside and then go for
this
feels weird
let's try this
i'd really like to exchange my bishop
off for one of these two
and is this too crazy
i'm gonna try this move
maybe i could play on the king side here
and then queenside castle
let's see
what the story is
all right
prepare
to queenside castle
just in time to fight for the h-file
this pawn stops the knight from jumping
in here so if i could activate that
bishop this bishop i would be happy so
if this queen
is somewhere else like wants to target
this i could go here
this move will probably be met with this
however
if
if that's played maybe i could think
about um
actually exchanging rooks and then
playing here to take the pawn
i like this little move maybe
yeah so case in point right here
suppose we chop
so do they want to babysit the pawn
or take with the king they want to take
with the kingy
makes sense
suppose this right now
or
what's wrong with just uh
doing this
and then uh
i really want to push here
also my clock oh what about uh what
about this move actually
i'm threatening some serious stuff no
like mate in two as well as a night move
here winning the queen
isn't this winning
i don't i'm not winning on the clock
what's the move man
what's the move
it's a queen
um
let's just have my
staff of this uh checking square
all right
let's let's mop everything up
this one's over
okay yeah they missed that uh
oh i mean i didn't calculate that uh
i didn't initially see that my queen was
opposite their queen i only was looking
in one direction
but once i had to move on i realized oh
there is another threat
i really felt like i needed to uh
come up with a good plan in that one
there because uh
that night drifting into
the king side was gonna be
a real bug
okay little shep
next opponent
hmm
who could argue with knight f3
okay let's get a maybe i should have
went with the duo first stop this
advance all right we're playing with the
trio
and
this one is likely to feel
a lot of pressure or
i'll probably end up moving it soon
set up this little pawn triangle
to negate the bishop once once struck at
i'm anticipating pressure here
um
so what am i getting at
i'm just trying to figure out what
bishop i should move
i'm gonna go for i'm gonna put the
bishop right here
and uh
i don't know maybe i end up putting
putting both bishops
on these two okay so no knight here
all right let's castle
all right and now we get
some space
so this
controls that guy really well
next phase
take a step out
to
control knight
no pivot
flight square as well
and
[Music]
put the rook here
and the bishop here
looking for a trade you could also go
here
in which case
i will do what
what diagonal will i stay on
if night here
uh i think of this one because i want to
get this exchange
right now it's
you know if it functions in that x
direction really well from f4
but
can really only focus on one key
diagonal if questioned
um do i want to put up a fight for the
e5 square
or look forward to bishop h6 okay
that i am almost certain is
not a good choice this knight will
like this square one day and also this
is springing to mind already
um
is now that time
i actually like uh addressing the
bad bishop at this very moment
and it's only because of this last move
that i'm beginning to think about that
although maybe i could have
thought about it
sooner but as soon as this square is
weakened you know this
this this diagonal kind of jumps out
this is a hole
and i did
i did see that uh
that is a move
i am able to defend i'm not able
or uh
i don't believe why disabled or black is
able to take advantage of the pin i'm
giving up on this idea to try and
exchange dark square bishops in this
case so
i want to be able to secure my queen
position for sure i want to be able to
take the knight out
pawn push
okay
um
hmm
i guess i'm not taking on possum
let's see
just playing a little defense
if knight here i was gonna back off
i'll stay here now that i don't need to
defend a c4 with my queen anymore
okay
gotta go here
defend that point
oh
that's that one hurts
maybe a mouth slip
let's win some material
and i'm just gonna take here
and before
i'm willing to give a pawn back just to
make sure files open up for my extra
rook
it's not a full
extra rook of course but i just want
the rook i have to have a purpose
and
i guess we go here i don't even want to
see this uh
structure
have any damage
so
let's go here
you want to take a step over
colleen's on a secure square
i just want to play b3
king here double up
maybe push upon
oh let's just scoot over actually
that was silly they're gonna nab this
pawn
i get it back though
rook takes rook takes bishop takes b2
i could get that
i'll find activity for my rooks okay
let's just save the pawn
um actually let's um
let's not lose on time
three seconds there
okay now now now i'm cool with doing
this here
here
and let's let's get this this bishop is
actually a bit annoying to be
sure yeah
okay this this is the perfect spot i
feel
defense
attack
i gotta go faster
and you hide over here
a light square is where you want to be
okay
now i'm ready to slither on in
all right
back up
get ready to push through
run
run
i want the full queen
needed to stay on this diagonal if it
was to sack itself
for the pond
all right they resigned
everyone is flying
speedy players
he-man the boss hello to you you're the
first the first time joining the stream
well hello
uh desert bug
thank you for the tier one resub 13 in a
row you say beat the pats
yeah
that would be something
it would turn our season around
if that happened
peter zwindler
peter swindler excuse me
thank you for the primary sub 4 nero
dgdv thank you for the 500 bits
ah phony
thank you for the tier one sub
second time around thank you for the
primary sub
20 in a row
josh o'nater
thank you for the primary sub 8 in a row
you add thanks for all the awesome
streams and videos jerry keep it up
sure work tap thank you for the tier one
resub two years on the nose now
two years of chess thanks jerry you had
all right let's let's do it again
taliman
one thank you as well
for the prime sub there you are
frozen over
what's going on
you say
you're a chess noob and you're just
learning the fundament fundamentals by
uh by watching
nice of you to join
if you have questions i'm sure there are
many experts in the chat that can help
all right
important to challenge this guy right
now
if this i could take and after that now
i could break up
what would normally be a very strong
pawn chain
so immediate pressure
on e5 is the first
step
chop chop these doubled pawns are
just imaginary they will naturally
undouble
and i am
this is one of the last examples
uh this game right here
is an example i shared in the stop
before you chop a video
when to chop on d6 when to chop on d5
the game i shared there was a a big
delay
tension was maintained
on this point
on these two squares as well
and it is still present let's get on
with castles
i'm also doing okay now that's a bit
different
oh was i supposed to hunt that bishop or
something
like here and then here no that's if the
queen is there
okay
how do i respond to that move
here here and then fiend keto or
i mean for right now i mean it's it's
uncomfortable for the knight to move as
soon as the knight goes here i have this
as soon as the queen goes
here and maybe i don't know
uh my bishop do i think i'd ever played
here
i feel like i should be fiancadoing
um
i don't need two steps i don't know
just one probably
i'll go one
no no no no no no no here's a reason not
to go there
there's this move or this move taking
advantage of my unprotected knight
okay so that said
hmm
i mean this is coming up soon too
should i play f5
let's go here first
what am i doing if queen here
how am i defending h7
it's clearing the way for this it's one
thing
i think i mean i want to go here
if there's a punch thrown at h7
it's important that i have both uh
at least a bishop controlling g5
otherwise there's the greek
gift stuff
chop chop here without
important to have this guy there
familiar
sacrifice on the king side
aha
so
i think it's time
to take that knight
and now take here
and have these guys split so i there's
some weaknesses
um
i have one less night
to worry about attacking my king
i really want to move this guy i want my
bishop here where's a good spot for this
knight
i mean trying to put pressure here it
feels like it's just so easily defended
so should i just get on with moving my
knight
i'd really like to drift over in this
direction uh
hmm
i'm also low on time
yikes yikes yikes
still gonna go here
put my rook here
i'm prepared to go here yeah
especially with that move around
yes
let's back off
ooh
my opponent may have a very good move
may
gotta go faster
i was thinking here okay i i'm gonna
take
here and have my queen defend some
squares
to fend off this stuff
it's currently threatening the bishop
but if i mean if this i can't even take
it because of the mate threat
let's just back off i'm coordinated
still want to get this in if these
knights are exchanged boom
like i would not mind seeing night there
boom boom
still need to get this guy
out of there
let's take a step up actually i think
this is a good
good idea oh forgetting that there's a
night move here
i could give it a kick but i did not
calculate this there's um
it feels funny it feels funny for sure
it's like one of those just
held together by a thread
i think
defense
i need some d fence man
let's go here
yikes living
off of the increment
i might have to get free like this
this pawn is unprotected you know
how do i ever make progress
i could take that pawn right
oh you dummy
i need to do that first
ah
that was a good move
just trying to
trying to hold this one
i feel like
it's a it's a draw
i need to put my bishop
i need to put my bishop on e8 first
this is the square this is the best
square for my king so
yeah i was defending and just before
i knew it felt a little funny
instead of king there
i need to go here first
and then one two three
this was a nice move
very nice move
okay a draw on board
i'm probably lucky to have the draw
because it really felt like that
should have been broken so
i'll look back at that game the computer
will cry out hey
you could have won this way
this way in this way
team white
yeah
the pressure
there was a lot of it
i guess we'll try a king's indian attack
try to go on the offensive here
frosty balrog thank you for the tier one
sub
appreciate it man
time to fianchetto
all right
muzza mill 212 is going right after my
throat
with this queen side play
now it feels a bit early to do this
normally the king's already castled
king side
and i have not okay i should probably
say like this normally i see b5 only
after white has made a commitment with
e5
but it's still volatile in the center
which makes me um
think more about maybe initiating an
exchange possibly taking advantage of an
unprotected rook or knight
i think i'll still hold off here keep
this tension
make the move i know i'm gonna have to
make and now now something is really
crying out
um something feels off with these last
two moves
my black
so
do i chop
and then uh get to the e file or
i mean am i even able to take advantage
of these two moves
well let's still keep the tension um i
don't know if i want to take or push
look at these guys man what a score 173
172.
we'll see if they keep it up here okay
well i can't take anymore
but i could give a push
and then dive in here
yeah i mean this
this must be correct
okay
and
i was tempted to go here
but
this also has uh its points
because i could uh
it cannot be supported the rook is not
defended so i could gain access to c4
with a4
and i think i'm gonna do that
yeah so i could jump into c4 now i like
this square better than this one who
knows maybe i want to pivot like this as
cave manish as it looks
cave manish
now if i want to just lock down the
queen side i do this but it's not
without its issues
can i work around that night
feels like i have to bend over backwards
to do that
so
let's not
um oh you know what i could go for
a night maneuver
right here
and then here i'm also clearing the way
for my queen to contribute
i'm uh keying in on this square
[Music]
maybe i just bring my queen out yeah
let's do that first
castles
if i went here black black can maybe
take the pawn all right
so no uh
no no no no no i have a check i could
throw in
yeah
let's just go here
i want to make sure this pawn is around
so where's their king going
now this is looking kind of serious
also ideas to capture and push through i
don't know if the bishop's not there
what i have two pieces on this though
what's that about
they missed that i had two pieces on
this
let's just back off
okay
i had one second i should not be
allowing it get down to one second when
you're up a piece like
this why am i not capturing the knight
nobody knows
now
we have a million pieces on this point
oh yeah yeah
okay i have a lot of material
i'm willing to give some of it back
just to unleash these
these monsters
check
just break it up
check
really all rook up and over
mate
in two
okay
yeah they just had a blind spot for some
reason there they thought
maybe they were thinking oh the the
queen isn't seeing this square anymore
or something
and just missed the
number of attackers and defenders was
off there
it happens
maybe they thought it would thought f6
oh
oh right yeah you br you raise a good
point f6 with the fork to get the piece
back but that pawn was pinned right
see what you're saying
yeah that could have been it as well ah
it's
sammy in the chat
hey
don't you be listening right now
don't you dare try to tune into my
stream sammy
all right
all right let's do something different
uh
let's go with the queen
d4
um
important to have this check and reply
to c4
is otherwise i get steamrolled
so now this is a serious threat to give
my queen a kick and then my knight a
kick and
this knight really doesn't have a great
square
so now's the time to say
let's put a stop to this id and my e
pawn now controls d5 so my knight is
going to be secure
the downside with this is that the
bishop will
be a problem piece like it was in that
other game
this c3 sicilian
all right now's the time to chop
and
and what
um
i'll go one step
knight c3 we'll go here which on the
surface looks like it's a maybe not a
good choice because of this but uh
i'm actually okay if the knight drifts
towards the queen side because there
isn't a great follow-up
and uh this this idea to try to connect
on the c7 square
is not there because of a timely night
kick and then i could uh
um get in a queen side expansion i think
that's uh
it kind of works in my favor if the
knight goes here
okay some pressure against b7
how do i deal with this
i could offer a queen exchange
actually
i think i like that idea
let's go for a queen exchange
and if my queen is exchanged how am i
recapturing
i'm going to say
with this knight because
i want to focus on
this home
in my bishop is a time to solve my
problem bishop here
hmm
yeah i mean i'd really like to get this
and then here if i could get these two
moves in i'm happy
you know a flight square would not be
now is not the time for a flight square
this is actually
doing something
um while it is kicking my knight to a
square it may just simply like and
actually
maybe
okay i'm recapturing with the knight for
sure i do not want to see this rook
invade so easily
um and actually now i'm i'm thinking
that if knight here
not only do i maybe have bishop here
but
i can just back off okay so now i think
i'm at least equal
so let's go here start to compete
for this open file
and if not here i could always uh back
off like this
and do that
so it's a strong piece but it's a it's
offset at the same time it's also uh
temporary i could give it a kick
we both have
strong night posts
[Music]
all right now is the time to uh
flush that knife back if not here i have
this square
i would what what i would like to have
here is a
a light square bishop exchange
okay let's begin with this move actually
if i can i'd like to have a
i'd like to keep one rook on board
so i'm kind of hinting at this move
right now even though my pawns would be
doubled and isolated
i want to keep one rook on if i can
because i feel that uh
um
i'll be able to target maybe
my opponent's uh pawns a bit easier than
than they can of mine
uh you know
um
let's
yeah let's let's do this even though
they're doubled and isolated
i don't know that they're so accessible
this knight on f3 is out of play
am i king okay i actually still just
don't mind
the double isolated pawns
i'm going to come over here
it also creates a pivot point on
this knight tries to get in here i mean
i have this move to
control
and if they are doing this from i am
putting pressure on this what would be a
backward pawn
okay so now i've basically done the best
i can with my king what else is there to
improve
okay
take with the rook
okay so if i take the bishop has to take
oh that's a blunder
because i could take with check and if
king takes to lose the bishop
and if bishop takes i have knight c3
so that was a bit too fast this idea to
trade
all rooks so now i'm winning
a full piece
okay yeah they
they missed
those forcing moves
good game sammy
there you are in the chat
throwing a purple heart my way
good game man
if you're gonna compete in this whole
tournament
make sure you take good care of yourself
take some breaks
it's needed
okay
let's
be a fighter
with the c pawn
my c pawn is better than yours
what's this knight up to
all right
um
queen here now
yes
yes
queen v6
queen here here doesn't win material
but it will force
force wise white to open up the a file
anyhow
um
let's get this guy playing
i think black is already better in this
position
this is uncomfortable for the queen
[Music]
she'll soon feel pressure on the c file
so
i think uh
for both sides
we enjoy fine positions for our minor
pieces
where i feel there's an advantage for
black is uh the better
the better pawn structure however slight
it is
these guys are
it's the same story here
but this is where there's a great
difference symmetry on the central files
but the c file
the big difference is uh
you know
the placement of the c pawns is
influencing the quality of the queenside
knights
i might as well do this right now i
don't know if i'm really even
threatening
maybe i am threatening stuff
chop maybe chopping twice i don't know
okay yeah they felt the pressure
they they sensed something okay so now
they're releasing the tension
they're giving up a center pawn
for a flank pawn so i have a central
majority
i'm gonna recapture with
the piece that was not yet playing
this bishop is a little short on squares
this knight is not normally here
it's normally here so
the bishop has some retreat squares so
i'm kind of eyeing up
maybe something
to get the bishop
[Music]
castling
is in a way a demotion
king's safety but my rook
maybe wants to do something on the h
file
i'm kind of drawn towards this plan i'm
not sure
why
um let's let's go for this maneuver
just i feel oh
i don't know
let's do it
take towards the center
i like this with this group of pawns
they're an island of five
okay
that's creating some unnecessary
weaknesses
unnecessary roughness here
white's going to get flagged for
unnecessary oh i'm losing a pawn here
check
really going pawn grabbing
no way
i have some
some
some stuff happening over here
really gonna go pawn grabbing
here here i have mate
here here i could take this pawn
oh man
queen is defending this
okay time to backtrack
it's not the end of the world i'd prefer
not to be down any material though i'm
being honest can i scoop up another pawn
probably
[Laughter]
probably
now they have some passers over here
okay
i understand
well that went wrong
all right all right
okay what i'm doing right now is really
really bad
i'm trying to attack and there's not an
attack
now my rook looks so clumsy here
i'm lost
i do have a pawn here
i don't know how i stopped these pawns
i need my knight to help
my rook
all pieces need to help
yes
hide my king
try to push that knight
could go wrong
look here
this
is maybe a move
doubling the rooks
gonna take here
so greedy man
so greedy
i'm so passive here
yepper
yeah
oh that's
that's sad
queen check that i didn't see f4
as a defense i thought i would win e3
that queen from a7 defends e3 i'll have
to remember that next time
oh
every every marathon there's a
disgusting game that's that's one of
them so far
uh
one of the good positions spoiled fast
not fun
oh i'm playing this guy again
huh
alrighty
let's see
[Music]
all right let's go for this
pa buttle thank you for the tier one
resub 17 in a row
let's put the knight out
okay
prepare to take
and chop
and
challenge
and then dive in
okay
attempted to play well yeah i mean
that's actually what i'm signing up for
diving in like this
upon sack
in order to get uh
the d5 square
i think i like the queen here more than
the night
maybe i
maybe i'm greedy and grab the apon
just go way out of my way
grab the a pawn
meanwhile they're trying to kill me
trying to justify
that rook left
uh huh
interesting
i would like a queen exchange here
not considering the night capture spawn
i'm just trying to figure out what
what the story is over here on the king
side
am i going to be hurting soon
all right
let's put a rook on a
an open file
yeah
i feel like i want to want the rook to
be there just so the queen
queen uh
queen can't get there
as easily
yeah
this is looking pretty serious
as much as i hate doing this i think i
i think it's important i play this move
i give up this square but i stop these
ideas to coordinate
and give mate
all right
back you go
knight
oh maybe this is the square
now they're threatening this or are they
no the knight would be hanging
so
boy this is this is going to be tough to
defend
i don't know that i can defend it
i'm going to say
put a rook here
for starters
see i want to do this but i think the
queen would nab this pawn and then have
access to f
f6
well
i could do this
and if queen here i could defend this
pawn
and then do this next
i'm uh
okay knight there this just gotta go i
gotta get rid of this knight he's too
good
okay
i think i've defended i'm not getting
mated soon
i want my queen i think back here
um
[Music]
yes
let's go here
this is the extra pawn it's backwards i
don't want it to get rolling
that was the threat now that this is
supported one move earlier i was able to
take
any forks no
this rook oh this rook is maybe stuck
like if queen here what about that
okay could i uh
you're trying to kill me here
feeling the pressure
i think that's a good move
i want to get this in
yeah i'm in trouble
i wasn't expecting that move
once more worse in this
rook and pawn ending
just trying to get that pawn back
i have nothing better
okay
a draw i'm lucky for a draw lucky to get
a draw
pepsi blue fan 2
thank you for the tier 1 sub
pick us two
all right let's try f4
you add no problem teacher
are we going to get a move from pikas 2
no move
a quick two
for me
a zemline let's stick with f4
the bird
the birds opening
spicy pickle what's going on
fiend kiddo
you think 270 points will get you top
50. i don't know i didn't do any of the
calculation
okay
shooting for e4
let's go here
first
this is a nice square for the night
also i'm in a spot to offset the knight
if he wants to fight
he wants to fight
try to eye up the f2 square i have
enough defense for it
anyhow i'm playing with a nice pawn duo
and i'm now a step away from
giving that knight a boot i think i
might want to do that right now
yeah
space
really
are you down
i'm not afraid to capture with the pawn
and have my pawns doubled
it's time to
time to flush that night away i think so
if i if i do this maybe maybe then this
starts to become an issue
[Music]
no it's not an issue
here i'm prepared to do this and uh
it just kind of blocks
not kind of it does it blocks the c pawn
so i don't have to worry
well it takes a little bit more time if
this guy wants to get rolling on the
queen side
they could try to combat this but it's
not without its weaknesses
e6 is weakened it's a whole
g6 is a little
a little more weakened so this here if
bishop takes knight i must take with the
pawn as otherwise this will
hurt me
um and second thought maybe it was was
better to do this and then uh this move
next
because now the queen has the reply to
take on b2
um either way i think
everything should start with this
maneuver to sideline the knight
so i'm
my pawns are drifting away from my king
side but with
a purpose
and also another
id to be familiar with
and it wasn't until
late in my
chess playing experience did i realize
that this is a
a nice tactic which is f5 takes
g5 and the knight is trapped
okay in that move
if i take you have to take with the pawn
as otherwise there's a fork in coming
so my center is feeling some heat
suppose this this and then g5 i don't
like giving that knight that square i
think i want to hold on to this point
maybe not even budge with um
this pawn
because i'm just asking for the
c file to be opened up
i'd like to go here
but without dropping the pawn
afraid of greedy players like here here
and then some
capture
let's just make a move
let's see
you take me
open up my bishop open my open up my
brook
this pawn gets in the way okay
maybe now i just take one step
with my bishop
[Music]
um
let's maneuver my night i think i think
there's going to be a serious amount of
pressure on this soon so
yeah now i am
really
i mean i have my sights set on simply
making sure this pawn is there and it
required the support of my c pawn really
so
i'm backed up a little bit but so is
black i think if i could uh maintain
this uh things are
are do are all right
i'm doing all right
we'll see
okay
um
my knight
where does my knight want to be
i think my bishop first of all wants to
uh
be here
and actually let's get this moving i
don't want to even see the knight think
about pivoting
on this square although this i'm giving
up this square
can't have it all can you
all right well let's let's come back
over here this i could think about this
square
my knights are on good squares
i figured the knight would have done
this what are they doing with the queen
side still have
to
work out some stuff there
kind of pond moves would i make on the
king side i'm not sure
clean side is clogged up
okay
let's go here actually prepared to work
around uh
a night once it arrives here
i could think about going into this
square
what's less on time
just make some moves
when in doubt just make moves that's all
okay captures are happening
fight for that square
no
i don't want that knight to be freed
queen trapped
she trapped
she trapped
very soon
queen here i get the queen
okay that was a lot of shuffling
early on and then some bullet scramble
where
someone blundered
all right
the mechaniac thank you for the prime
resub 2 in a row noun 35 total
you add hi jerry
you add hi jerry non-smart next opponent
um
okay let's try a four again
chop once but that's it
i don't want to see my knight get kicked
so
e4 it is
right here what's that knight up to
i don't know
here
here here am i afraid of this no
here
back off
if i could get castled
these these pieces will work well
against f7
here
okay
a moment to do
a thinker here a little thinker
here
here
chop
queen takes i'm not afraid of knight
takes with this idea to push no that's
not there because of the pressure here
okay let's just castle
so this is a big square for me if there
aren't uh
they could go for queen exchange too
they don't want the queen exchange
huh
i want my knight here
but it's not there
tactically
knight h4 there's night here no i could
still do that
knight here
night here or here let's see knight h4
knight here i could go here and defend
my knight on h4 knight here here i have
knight f5
no i don't
knight f5 there's then queen here
hitting my queen
queen takes there's night takes
i have a check king here and then i can
win this pawn but it doesn't feel right
i feel off balance there
okay
let me start with this move then
with this idea
which would
be
winning there's also this pawn
it is pinned
um
yeah so this is my idea i want to unmask
my rook my night getting here
f5 be real nice
check
duck
this is still serious okay
question to the queen
okay
let's go here
i still i want i don't want to go here
my knight wants to go here now for this
this knight would be unprotected there
would be two unprotected nights they'd
have to connect
so
night here i have this
and we'll see have to be careful
i mean i i could have gone here too but
no
this would be a blunder
there's also even night here
because of this uh
this move a knight
on this square okay so they're trying to
influence my uh
my bishop but do i even need to uh
react to that
yeah i think i do
and i'm gonna i'm gonna go to
actually do not mind that the queen is
here the knight was the one piece that
was scaring me more even though this hit
with check
exerting pressure on this bishop which i
think is one of my best pieces in this
position i think would have been better
where to go with my knight
um
here
maybe i could get to this square i don't
know i need some work before i could do
that feels a little uncomfortable
there's some okay now now this is
actually
something and i'm once more threatening
this this stuff
i'm gonna go faster let's go back home
on the queen now
dummy
had mate basically
had a fork there
ah missed my chance it's still a very
good position i don't like my king here
i don't know why
i really went there
let's just back off
i should really get my queen doing
something huh
sacrifice on this square
looks like they're ready to sacrifice
here
maybe i should just centralize
i had this move
there's a lot of ways i could have won
material by now
here it is folks
okay
didn't want the rook getting there
two threats
when the bishop went the pawn
night there much earlier would have been
good
okay
all right they resigned
ah
i had
my pieces in good spots
got to be
tactically sharp i wasn't it wasn't
there though
it's not tactically sharp
okay
um
let's try the budapest gambit
very rare
for me to play this
uh
let's go here
just try to
get the pawn back
and
yeah let's just take them right away
hmm
um
all right
let's just develop i'm worse here
white has a better
pawn center although now i have an
opportunity to
convert my third ranked pawn into
fourth ranked pawn
now how to take
hmm
if here night here
i think i'll end up having to give up my
bishop so
let's take my bishop
and what next
hmm
huh
let's go here i'm a bit concerned about
an f4 move okay
all right maybe i go here now
at least i could consider taking the
knight if it goes there
it's not going there no no i'm really
thinking about queenside castle i like
this idea to queenside castle
and fight for the d5 square with pieces
instead of a pawn i mean
something that was crossing my mind
earlier was a night retreat
to fight for this square but all right
it still
could very well be a move
i have to deal with so
where this night jumps concerns me okay
i think maybe getting some rooks off
would be
a good idea some rooks
getting both rooks off
let's see
and i think i'm going to take with the
bishop once more i like having this uh
possibility available and also i should
probably have f6 in soon i don't want to
have a
this knight constantly
there to defend
e5 i want to construct f6
f6 and
e5 to negate the bishop in short
although
although
maybe losing a pawn if i try to do that
so if this knight here hits this and
that
so
i may
need to play bishop here
or just play this and allow bishop takes
knight
or what about knight here
hitting this pawn
let's try this
i mean my night okay they're going oh
wow really
huh
all right i'm going to take that pawn
and get this guy
i mean without the a pawn i have dreams
at least of let's say an outside passer
my knight feels a little stuck
all right let's go pawn hunting i don't
know
so down on time
tough man it's a tough position
i want to be able to kick that knight
away
oh they're winning upon that oh my
night's stuck where am i going with my
knight
ugh
oh now my knight's dead
here i have a trick to get out of it but
that move i do not have a trick
oh
man
sad
very sad
i could probably resign this
yeah i'm gonna resign that that was
really bad
my knight was
wandering
on their side of the board without
squares
i know that knight on d5 was too strong
i did not address that strong knight
post on d5 very well
i want to put good pressure on me
all right
back on the horse
200 has been broken
banya
thank you for the 500 bits appreciate
that man
okay let's play in the center
let's do it
trying to maintain e5 i want to put some
pressure on e5
try and overtake the strong post
the strong position of
the e5 pawn it's been overtaken
okay
now where does the bishop belong
i say here
here with caution
with caution
i'm so scared of that i'm gonna go here
here and then feel more comfortable
about
uh
castling so let's let's just drop back
now i could
go here if they try let's say a queen
exchange okay
why is everybody a wizard when they play
against me
okay
just
it seems so easy
i thought that was a moment to strike at
the center
and then dive in
so fast man
so
fast
right
huddled up over here on the king side
what great things can i do
i feel like now is maybe a good moment
to take that bishop i feel like the rook
is demoted
it's unprotected i don't know if there's
anything great happening on the a file
or the or this rank
this knight will be coming here soon
anyhow
maybe not still keep the tension
let's go here
fight off this night move
okay
take towards the center i have i have to
worry as much about
my e4 pawn now so my knight could feel
um
you know now that this pawn is securing
this point this knight shouldn't feel
like he has to uh defend e4 so he could
think about this square
which is uh
all the more appealing i must say
because
there isn't a black light square bishop
around so this is likely
going to have to be played
[Music]
let me let me go here
for a couple reasons
well one main reason actually i want my
g pawn to contribute
and if that
which is
um
yeah
that is a move
okay let's go here
still stay out of this guy's way
feels a little bit clumsy
i want my i wanted my knight here and
then this
yeah let's keep it closed
i want this guy to be brought to life
so these guys are potential targets for
this this guy look at the rook lift
all right g pawn
do something
dangerous
here's met with this
that move is met with what
i may be all right with no i don't
really want to take that okay what about
this move defense
pressure here are they going to
sacrifice maybe
okay
huh
this knight
all right let's go here
let's get out of the line of fire
a little pressure here
black pieces do have some defensive
roles right so the pressure i have on
these two so for example this
is what i'm referring to
i'll probably do this real fast as if
it's planned it wasn't planned
it wasn't planned
no way
you did not plan
to give up that rook
no way
i don't believe it
just don't believe it man
[Music]
let's see what the defense is to this
bishop back
maybe just something to defend that
point
none of the above
that's me
okay they were a speedy player
a tough player to play against the
speedy players
bombs 13 thank you for the tier 1 resub
20 in a row
you add marathon time let's go
trying
let me
keep it there
okay
second time playing this player not in
this tournament though
okay let's get a move in
all right let's let's feed keto
why not
let's try a grunfeld
rare to see me playing this
mm-hmm
okay
i don't know
i just know some
basic stuff put pressure on d4
after e4 here and chop they're prepared
to take like this i think i still do
strike at the center though
with c5 i'm backing off
is this also a move
i'm going to say let's still take and
still
have my c pawn contribute
okay
feels like my opponent knows exactly
what they're doing
okay
let's take that guy
okay
all right
oh no no no no no no no no
it's okay if you take me i guess i want
to make sure this knight is gone i'm
going to try and fight for the dark
squares
that's my plan at least some knight
versus bishop position
try to get my knight on let's say this
square
you know if i could construct a pawn
here night there
something something to that effect
so i may want to uh just voluntarily
give this guy up otherwise there may be
a retreat a light square bishop exchange
that night could be quite the pest
helps support uh central pawn advance
very well
[Music]
let's begin with queen here
and then knight here
it's a developing move
okay my king is accessible now along
this diagonal one
square okay this knight doesn't have
anything better than d7
let's go
i'll just say this crossed my mind but i
you know to if i could play this knowing
that i could get this move in next
i would love that
but this move will be met with the
capture and then
i'm really going to feel some pain along
the e file
so
no thanks
rook c8
rook c8
hmm
is now maybe even the time for this and
then this
like if i do this bishop here won't i
struggle to get in c4 so this here i
could think about that
probably be undermined soon
i may have to go
i may have to
prepare it a bit a bit more
also this this move
you're also using a lot of time here
no no
don't ask me how i came to that
conclusion
after all that
uh
let's go here
um i'm kind of leaning towards
i don't know
gotta go faster
i want to be able to make this with this
i don't know
all right let's try this
see if i could get my knight to c5 i may
have to play up six actually
you know let's do that
week in this square but i don't know
maybe i could work around that bishop
yes
i don't want to see this move
i want to go here this was probably a
dummy move yeah rook to d8
what's up with that
this is where you belong
all right
giving up a pawn
where am i oh that's a move actually
i have a passer
i just saw that at the last second this
was a maneuver all along wasn't it
okay i have a connected past not a
connected it feels connected in past
this is past
let's go here
maybe i went upon and actually i could
seal my queen in soon with h4
threatening this pawn
should uh this is this is i think uh
it's a good positional idea we'll see if
it pays off i'm down a pawn but a strong
knight
superior minor piece
i don't want to see my queen kicked
i don't want to see this kind of pawn
roller i need to control these dark
squares
and let's come back they may have just
uh been threatening to push
bishop there
oh i'm threatening oh i had to move i
had this move
i have it now
queen takes i take the rook had that one
move sooner
tricky
queen is restricted
hmm
win a full rook
i'm on this
is my night going to get hunted
defending this
oh that you could take like that
centralize the queen
why not take the pawn
oh i guess i want to stop this advance
that's why
okay here and then here it's also an
idea let's do it
i want to have this square in mind
let's check
check here and then here you dummy
let's try it again
finally you have to go into a pin
and now you hit the pinned piece
now mate in a couple on the dark squares
okay
made on board this idea
i probably could have um
i don't know
i did i wanted to stay off of this
earlier
but this right here once i got to this
point this idea
the push like that
is important
just curious about
this sequence
is that what's called for c4
come on
c4
and then b4
yes
it's still
a tough game
zero
but important positional idea there
back in the tournament there
okay
uh just jk thank you for the resub prime
three months in a row
and
yosarian80 thank you as well for the
twitch prime sub i appreciate your
support
okay
team black
all right
let's try and make this a d-pawn based
opening
because this guy is
won't contribute let's see they're gonna
try to uh
do what
let's go here
no they're not going for e4 so my
question is
how
will white
get a pawn break okay what they might be
gunning for
is this and then drifting in here
all right well
i basically said with my last move that
my bishop isn't going to come outside
the pawn chain so let's get this guy
here
and now i'm prepared to play c5 right
now yep right now
okay well
took two two moves to get there i think
this is where white is going astray
with this plan
this guy right here is after all the
good bishop
so it may turn out white is very
vulnerable on the light squares if this
exchange occurs and i think that's what
white's prepared to do is otherwise
uh you know this this expansion for me
on the queen side is desirable
why not grab a little space on the
queens
on the queen's wing
yeah let's just get on with it i'm not
really considering anything else i'm
going to take with the bishop
or
yeah i'll take with the bishop this is
fine
wow
okay so this is
what it's a bishop pair versus night
pair position are they going to go in
for this
okay folks it is
it is what it is
a mass
exchange position
okay
queen
exchange even though it helps the knight
i take here you have to take like this
hmm
otherwise i win a pawn next
yeah let's create a little imbalance
with the structure i like this pawn
controlling the knight once it's on f3
and let's let's go here right away
uh my king will find a nice home here my
bishop is
is nice here as well and actually it may
be that i
went upon
straight away this bishop
start to see it contribute actually
normally
it feels like a post on d7 is only there
to connect rooks but it's serving a
purpose
here to get this rolling and this is not
a fun way
to have to defend and am i just going to
win a pawn
right because king
well
okay now i could win a pawn i think but
it is not without its drawbacks
because i still am backed up
behind a development
so
what about this in queenside castle
or
[Music]
or
actually i like this it feels like a
better contributor
on h6
there here
um
yeah let's get this moving now because i
want to be able to do this here here
take and not worry about this move with
check
so
okay now i believe we're ready to
finally
push through like this and grab a pawn
or am i still
you know
this knight's gonna circle in here what
am i
it's a little bit too fast there maybe
my bishop should be here
here takes here
i guess i could
grab another pawn and try to push here
but there will be some pressure on me i
would prefer to kind of just have a pawn
in my pocket
and not have to defend at all
but i guess i'll have to do a little
defending
we'll see
yes
grab another pawn
and grab another pawn
i may have a little back and forth
actually
there here and then knight back
that move
looking at this and to get rid of the
night
the timing i think is just
barely there
not without the counter play right
there's this square
yikes
yeah let's get running with this guy
he's got to go
hmm
okay
here i have this square covered
am i just getting a queen next
there's no checks good checks
this pawn actually shields my king now
from these guys
i don't know that was not clean
not clean at all
all right that's just
gotta go
let's get out of
there run with the other one
let's get rid of stuff
oh
i didn't i'm not a fan of how i
approached that one i i probably should
have i'm thinking put my bishop on d6
instead of h6
that
got to an ending that required
a calculation
not that that's uh
i just i would pref i felt that there
was a way where you could do it where
you didn't have to calculate
a cleaner way
confirm or disconfirm thank you very
much man for the 1000 bits i appreciate
that
thank
you this is a that moment move five here
is
a moment where i say for sure
nights before bishops
i would prefer to know
um well i would i'd like to keep it uh
give black an opportunity to make a
bishop move
and then i get to decide well
you know if you go here maybe i
pin the knight or go here
i think um
i'm going to make a decision now with my
light square bishop
which of the two
i'm going to say here
i think i just
if i go here they they go
there and then maybe kick maybe i could
have won a pawn i don't know
all right let's start with
i don't know
anyhow the nights before bishop thing it
was just holding off on a bishop
decision for one move in short
now let's go here
maybe actually it was probably better to
uh pin the knight
super dude thank you very much for the
36 bits
all right we've we've had this structure
before the one where i had an
opportunity to land a
to land a fork
it's not the same opponent
okay
now my my original intention was to
actually just take the knife but i don't
i don't really have to
i mean what about this move
here here may i don't know maybe it
makes for a
an interesting position or do i just
take here
now i just take here i think
yeah
and now
now i go here
that i was not afraid of
now i think i'm just better
i have a bishop that's on the same
colors my pawns but this is a super
active bishop
no counterpart here
castle yes
now
coordination on f7 is
it's there
i want to maintain my bishop
here
so
not this i don't even want to see this
move
um
i could push a4 maybe this pawn gets
targeted at one point okay
i could take here i'm also just looking
at maybe capturing and then having this
move
um
i'm going to take i i want to have a new
square for my bishop depending on what
the knight does so here i have this move
but let me let me consider
let me consider this check
king here
and then getting my queen
somewhere else
huh
hmm
maybe i should have
maybe i should have played in the center
to to stop this i don't know
down on time again grab that pawn or not
i don't want that pawn
i don't know i feel like i just don't
i just don't care about that pawn
let's get this uh
i do have a central majority maybe
maybe we'd do something with that
now i mean if i could have this bishop
here and then glue it in with a pawn
it's a different story i could start to
dream of some sacrifices on the h file
controlling g8
but it just feels like it's a pawn grab
and then i have to untangle to get out
of a pin
okay
let me put some pressure here this
there's also there's multiple pins going
on i'm also still defending this
um
i have a rook
okay i didn't see that that was even a
thing i could win this pawn now whoops
now i just feel like i'm worse
because i am worse
[Music]
where's my where's my bishop going
anyhow if it's challenged
i should have played here and i have
this square
tell me
i don't know it's probably going to go
up and get trapped
going to no man's land hide
run over here
i get this in
i needed to defend this okay
i'm giving this knight a good square
these pawns are connected and passed and
fast and all that good stuff hitting the
rook
hitting here
can i get my pawns rolling
five seconds
probably
just allow um this capture
my pawns can maybe be quick too
i am controlling a promotion square
if they if a4 okay they just they
definitely went passive these last
couple moves
right here i could do the sack
and then queen here check win the night
here right away the knight would take
and then yeah
why did i even go here
i don't even know what i'm threatening
i'm really going astray here i'm not
throwing any threats at my opponent and
i should
i could take the knight yes
blundered i'm on the rook there
oh
yo
should not have gone down like this
i got nine lives
oh man shouldn't have happened like that
i was toast
i should have played e5
i don't know well i'll tell you what
that ain't
there rook i could have done something
different there
i should have done something different
there in reply to their queen side play
i think they got the better me
after uh
a few moves after their
queen side advance
queen side pawn play
all right
all righty
play with the c pawn or the knight we'll
go with the knight
what's a difference here
with how you defend
i don't know
for one
if the c pawn stays around you don't
have this maneuver
take with the knight
here here is poison
now let's take what a piece
thought it was poison
i'm missing
there's no queen here
here there's this
queen check there's this
without fear of this little trick to
take advantage of an unprotected rook
because the knight is pinned
absolute pin
hawkeyes thank you very much man
for the 1000 bits
you add thanks for the excellent youtube
and twitch content
appreciate that man
okay i was tempted to go here but what
about this
oh forget about this
queen takes
we just exchange
no thank you so this move
instead
is the way to address that
checaroni
my knight is defending
and now i'm ready
to chop
with check
there we go
the only fear i have is some move here
uh maybe i do have another fear
ending up in a pin
okay if i could just get castled
this check here
okay i think i like this as a start
develops it defends my knight it frees
up my queen from this defensive role
and
and i could
do what i'd really just want to castle
king's side
all right let's just put my knight here
rather
rather not but
all right my knight just
goes to rank two for a moment
all right let's get out of it let's
check
and then castle
king's side
oh
take that with my knight
let's get the move back
yup
castle my bishop's defending my knight
could be kicked
but i am up a piece now and i am ahead
in development
so
oh also that uh i take here
is that that's not a move
um i could actually
i could do this
yeah and it's not just any pawn now i'm
threatening to go here there's no f6
defense against this pin
yeah do have that move
so fully developed up a piece
things are good now
okay now that they're in a pin
let's keep them in a pin
ready to take the knight and then take
here
don't lose track of time
please
all right let's do it
let's get the material
let's be a defender
i'm gonna grab this pawn with that
similar
similar trick
just don't get mated
all right
knight on h and a5 c5
watch out
light squares
centralize
that's a funny-looking move
can't let you do that man i can't let
you make me on g2
just can't
there was a mates right there
okay let's just be a
centralizer
defend everything
just in case
oh rush
look for the mates
okay
only the king can move
okay
straight to me
all right
ah
what time is it time flies
carnac
13.
stalemates were the only thing
towards the end there
on d5 okay
had a similar position before my
opponent's doing a
yeah the one where i had the the bishop
pair versus the knight yes okay so we're
getting to see this other this other
idea white has
with uh playing with the f pawn and
cementing the knight here
okay
what's the approach
c5
break the pin
i'm going to say let's break the pin i'm
prepared to move this knight
what's that move about
stopping a pin
not sure
really didn't
intend on playing that move
um i actually like this move because i'm
prepared to play here and i don't want
to see this knight
oh that's the idea
all right they're really trying to
make this bishop feel bad
yes you're trying to make this light
square bishop feel bad
[Music]
all right how can i maneuver to this
square
okay i think my knight's gonna try to go
for
a hike
this is uh turned pretty locked
yes
here we go
definitely nothing and kettling
well
i guess that was an idea
okay
hmm
i don't know if it's a good idea i'll
try it
run this for the
moment mm-hmm
let me play this move
let me try that prepare to back off here
of course it's my only square and then
at least i
i can't go there so
i'm going to play with this
my knight let's dance
and turn into quite the
maneuvering game
don't want to give this square up gotta
go faster
my knight needs some work i'm starting
to coordinate now on this square like
that
if this happens you know my bishop will
find life
where do i want to go with my king not
sure
in there
oh is this close to a move oh i mean i
could dive in here first
why not
let me try this idea
feels very slow but
this
within this move
okay now i'm going this way
you gonna sacrifice here okay
let's see
okay bishop
connor clean
queen
my knight wants to go somewhere else i
don't want this file to be peeled open
so fast
or at all
let's just drop back defend some squares
okay
after all this shuffling what has been
accomplished
i have a superior knight
hitting the rook stopping this
also stopping the rook from invading
right here
my king is close to now just sneaking up
here
maybe this move first
take control the file the rook has a
responsibility
let's take
and now
create an outside passer
possibly
okay i could switch
switch gears
find activity for the rook
be on the lookout for
forks
the past pawn
you're rolling
my rook dead
no
i should have captured that pawn because
of this trick
do this now
okay
put a lot of pressure on me there for
sure
you've been playing with two and a half
minutes
this whole time
king went to the third rank i had the
forced
rook exchange
i'm pushing through
a maneuvering game
okay they resigned
um
okay
katya
e4
hello shut up donnie in the chat
all right
let's go here
oh
knight jumps in
all right i'll take oh that's surprising
very surprising because now i get c3 and
then d4
normally i believe you go with the uh
the pawn as the recapture
okay
uh where to go with the bishop
here here here here eventually there's
a tempo against my bishop anyway i am
i think i probably should just go all
the way back home
make sure you know
i keep this defended d3 was not
an option maybe i could have for a pawn
sack okay
next phase
okay a little bit of a timing thing here
i want my knight on f3 let's get the
flight square in now
and i'm doing this
because i knew this move had to be
played and now i have the timing here
where i could go here
can't win out on d4 and next i have my
knight on its
favorite square
queen knight
will soon occupy the king knight's
favorite post
and now we can think a bit later about
this guy and what
what the bishop wants to do
has many
options which one is best i'm going to
say
now that there's some pressure released
here
i could consider this move
but i like still just keeping the center
just how it is
and i'm going to say let's
play bishop to e3
preparing queen to d2
also looking to just centralize
uh we'll see i mean
okay
i like this idea and queen on c2 doesn't
make much sense to me because the c file
can open up in the
the rook will gain a tempo against the
queen so this
seems cozy no matter what black decides
to do with the c pawn
the d file will not become half open for
black
reinforces this square
taking
taking with the pawn yes
uh control this knight i'll have a
question that answer
after there's pressure here and maybe i
just
continue
on this path
with bishop to h6 to eliminate
dark square bishop
best defender and hope for maybe uh an
attack against the king in the long term
these two pieces can maybe cause some
problems
for black on the dark squares
um yep let's go for it
black should not be inviting me in there
so they should keep the tension are
uh they are keeping the atten attention
so
hmm
i don't want to see the rook invade
maybe i just take and push what about
maybe just pushing right now what's
wrong with that
gotta make a decision
take
let's just go here for right now
centralize
i probably should have played this i
would rather play this move i think only
after the knight has moved
okay so now is that time because now it
can't make use of these squares on its
next turn
okay see i had a backtrack there okay
and now i believe that knight
simply belongs
on this square and i could now start
thinking about maybe
playing with my f pawn prefer to do
without it if i can
i would love a light square bishop
exchange and then
go here
huh
let's get my king up of this diagonal in
case i want to make the
the non-committal move first so king h2
and then this maybe this was better in
case this diagonal opens up
not sure
i could think about
maybe a rook up and over
thing
i'm just going to keep the knight out of
this square
i mean there is this to pivot but
let's see
here here here i think is nice
coordination
although i don't want to follow the rook
there
very cavemannish
i dare you to move knight
i don't know if i would really go for
that
now let's try this
let's go bishop here i'm anticipating
the night here
this may not be a bad idea
i don't know let's see if i could
oh i i i had i had a move night check
and then went upon i was already there
with the trick
okay let's back off i'm living off of
the increment
this is probably too much what i'm doing
right now
maybe not
okay
try to enter this this this feels like
it's working though
gotta go
oh
something juicy happening
i want my queen to be the one that
captures here the rook would be nice but
the queen is threatened as mate
these guys are
queen side committed
they're down on time
i don't know
it felt it felt harmonious
maybe maybe
i don't know
i don't know
if that was really
the best way
all right let's try this
thinking about this the other day just
the other day this quick night move
with then uh
well normally this pawns already here
knight move with them this idea
but they're they're not doing anything
about
me playing e5 let's get let's give e5
a shot
okay so they're not challenging with
this here and then this kind of stuff
so
bishop
to
some square
i want to stay off of this square i
think
which one
um
i'll go here
uh
not 100 sure why
uh i'm deciding on this i i feel like
it's less accessible to a night
and maybe
you know depending on how
you know there might if it closes in the
center this this post but by the night
uh you know moving my knight and then
the maneuver knight h4 into f5
isn't there anymore
let's go here
not sure what i want to do with this guy
yet okay now i'm thinking more about
this move
now that they're going for a queen side
fiend keto
i like this idea of playing here
but only after
only after let's defend this only after
white has challenged one of these two so
now this
right here
is that really the way yeah i mean it's
a way to play it i have some space and
if they go in this direction the rook
would much rather be on f1
isn't this
this is running into this move right
away this isn't a threat
and this is a valuable move
for sure
just want to make sure i uh
follow up properly
um
i think this is a good idea
here
take
and then here
secure my
knight and i could think about this but
i'm more
i'm more so looking at this move
here
trying to trying to maybe work with this
square
this post right here is fantastic for a
bishop
so how does this guy do
stuff
don't know
okay
they may
maybe doing
what here
no
i would love to see this move
this is the one that concerns me a bit
let's uh let's go with this move
i mean
can i do something as
as caveman like as that
just try to win this pawn
i'm gonna try it
this feels very pawn grabby
i must say
but
i mean
it's something isn't it
right because the knight's angling for
this square okay well first of all
they're saying you can't do that just
yet with your queen
all right let's go here first though
you know if queen goes here i could take
right away i'm gonna follow through with
this
feels weird and i could decide which one
you know if knight there i could take
with the bishop and there's a pin
if they try to counter-attack here
do i take with the bishop i'm gonna take
with the knight
keep the knight around
let's do it
let's take here
tempted to go here as well
yeah let's take there
i feel a bit off balance
is the thing
a bit off bounce oh they're going there
i figured they would have entered
got to go faster
i want a piece here like a knight here
oh they could just take that
okay
now if not here i have this
it'd be tricky to get out that pin
not easy to get out of the pin
there's still a pin
finally winning material is there's no
rook here
i have check at one check in the
position i'm just looking at it now
i have
you know if there's some trick here okay
i'll win some material now
let's get my knight doing something else
stop night here
try and create dark square weaknesses
okay got a square
i could
maybe attack the king
this
this this battery stuff
the queen
the queen bishop battery
the queen and bishop battery trick
ready to take and slither on in
look here
and we got me
a couple
check and then mate
okay a lot of attention on the queen
side and then just towards the end there
king side stuff
it all started with some space advantage
uh black pawn on d4 when all pieces were
still aboard
all minor pieces
jim jig a man thank you very much for
the twitch prime sub and loebfin
thank you for the tier one resub
52 months in a row for you now
thank you
you add thanks for keeping chess fun and
interesting
thanks man
alright let's roll with this one again
bishop b5
try to go a bit faster in the opening
stage
since we've been here before oh well
things were much different
my opponent played a night there
after rook to e1
yeah i got those valuable moves in
was that the game
it might have been a different game
anyhow
all right well i'm tempted to take this
knight now before the knights are
connected
let's go for this imbalance
and
let's play this right now so i'm
i'm trying to make sure that
this pawn does not contribute
so
that's why we're going there
if this pawn moves i take and then these
guys are
having a tough time
where is this knight going
well let's start
here
to get to this square
would be huge
okay
okay so here
queen here is the thing
and if i check take take knight here i'm
not defending that pawn i i need
let me let me consider though because
soon i think this is this is happening
my center
my only pawn that's trying to
impact black's
pawn duo is uh this guy
soon to be eliminated and then these
guys could get rolling
so here here
maybe i
still do this here
here
and if it goes if he goes hunting i just
open it up and
try for some pawn sack
this guy's got to be worth four anyhow
right
important defender
so let's see first of all if they're
gonna put pressure here
yep okay i guess we're gonna go down
this line
i'm gonna try to oh they're not taking
now that's surprising
yes that's very surprising
all right so
one or two
um
i'm going to say just one
because i don't i don't want to allow
this pawn to move so easy so if i go
here take take eventually there's this
and then that
so i do this
with uh restricting the bishop in mind
i could also
i could have considered this stuff
but uh something as natural as
developing my bishop to one of these two
squares all right so this i don't mind i
don't think i could take and then
probably should
take
i mean here
that that's a move too
ah i like just taking it i'm okay that
my knight can't be maintained here
anymore
so
i'm alright we're dropping back i have
something to bite at
and i have ways to maybe try and get rid
of the dark square bishop
here with this
here with this
i'm on this one first of all so let
let's hang out for a second maybe i just
win this pony i'm winning this pawn
and why not take it
let's take the pawn
try to remove them but i want this
knight to stick
stay on this square
let's uh let's begin building
right now
with this move
combats this and i'm looking to
negate the bishop glue the knight in
this is a really powerful piece my
current best piece
okay let's sneak in another one
okay that move
um
[Music]
how about
queen here
defend this and now i could think about
this kind of maneuver
just put my pieces on good squares i'm
working with a good structure
now this is all the more appealing queen
is also in a pin
i assume this pawn is in a pin
yes okay clean there
let's back off
yeah
this i was thinking about
this stuff still
but my queen has this responsibility
i have this move under control
um
let's go here
if i do this
this this kind of idea concerns me so
i'll just defend
with an attack
for now
gotta go faster
control these two brakes and i'm
controlling the bishop
on the rook right now okay let's let's
go back
this might have been too soon
i don't like giving that square up okay
i've got good pieces
good control
centralize
think about this soften black up a bit
let's get this guy going
grab a pawn
i don't want it though
okay
hey
spot my knight there
or my queen queen on h6
pawn moves i have this
up and over
on this
tight
tight game
on the clock
living off of the increment as usual
okay
let's do it
logan
first time playing
all right
let's throw the sicilian
at logan
all right
let us see
that move
um
i'm gonna opt for
a fianchetto
and uh
i'm going for this
with a what id in mind
well
i don't have to worry i think at least
about the normal yugoslav attack running
with h4h5
because our one to one tempo has already
been invested with h3
all right
i think this here is consistent with the
bishop on g7
the pressure here
if ever a capture
you know there's this stuff
i mean they could still try to kill me
no doubt
with this with this idea
but
let's see
let me actually try this
i do not have much experience so at
least this idea to play bishop h6 or
have this pawn challenge me isn't uh
isn't a thing anymore
but it is opposite sides castling
and can be scary
for sure
it can be scary
how they moved i didn't realize
[Music]
all right
well
um
let's try this move
f4 take
take
have night here
okay isn't that maybe a mistake
i could take here
and if this i have that move
when the exchange
or we enter some weird imbalance where
they give up their queen
[Music]
queen here i could at
minimum well maybe that's the best i
could do okay go hunting for the dark
square bishop
and i say let's do that
okay
and let's
crash through here
um
here
all right let's go here
and just you know this this can be
broken open for sure it's not without
giving up a big square and maybe a pawn
to me but i want to get this in i want
this knight to to come under fire
i want to ideally put pressure on the
dark square since i'm working with an
unopposed dark square bishop now
but it's not easily accomplished the
queen
the white queen does a good job of
preventing this natural deployment
that night i feel needs to go
so
yeah let's get rid of the knight see how
first of all black wants to or white
wants to recapture
like that
okay
hmm
now let's get my queen active
this pawn must be poison
if this i'm prepared to go here
i care more about trying to get an
attack here with the opposite colored
bishops and yeah that being the only uh
minor piece remaining and also the the
biggest factor opposite besides castling
still queens and rooks all majors on
board
this move if the queen isn't around
you know this move you don't really ever
want to play this because my queen
and bishop start to slither in
i think we do this move now
or get the rook involved
let's um
let's get this rook playing first
and there may be
i why didn't i consider maybe just
capturing
no no
oh oh cause maybe uh
okay could i do this right now
um
let's do this right now
i don't know how if i even want to
capture that pawn
here i could take now that the rook is
helping
oh queen there i didn't even consider
queen there
all right
gonna take in between or no they're not
taking their first i thought they maybe
should have grabbed a pawn
all right i guess we babysit that pawn
my bishop's gonna have to camp out here
let me get these moves in
okay
let us see
defend here
sneak over
i don't want this guy to expand
it's a tough battle
hmm
i think this bishop may have gone astray
i think it was needed to stop this pivot
and then eventual control
let's push
and go here
stopping rook uh bishop activity
hmm
let me try this even though it looks
scary
oh
i feel like i'm close to getting mated
and misplayed those last few moves for
sure
and my bishop is here
i couldn't grab that pawn because there
was check
pawn is rolling a bit
um
tight game
why didn't i take that
pawn let's try it again
oh man
craziest game of the tournament so far
i felt like my mind was pulled in so
many different directions with this game
so many different uh
i don't know
we transitioned
i don't know how to describe this one
imbalanced everywhere we look
i don't know the opposite side's
castling the
minor piece imbalance here
bishop versus knight and then opposite
color bishops
i think this one
should have been inserted before the
capture anyhow good game
what a fight
what a fight
i don't know what the assessment is here
i'm actually a bit curious am i just
losing here
where did it shift
right here once i got this this pawn
moving i think it shifts
right around here yeah
oh
okay good game good game
uh
past life karma thank you very much for
the 200 bits
and thank you to light to new york for
the tier one resub
52 excuse me 54 months in a row now for
you
thank you very much appreciate it man
all
right uh
back to tournament land
okay ah lance
lance is berserking me
that was expected
lance is a berserker
okay
oh he doesn't play the uh grunfeld
he's a king's indian guy
irate
all right here's the plan here is the
plan
all right
now you're going to take
all righty
let's put this guy here
i'm tempted to take here just to have
this bishop blocked
maybe
okay
what about now
let's do it now
alrighty
it's offering a draw
no
it's where the night belongs
i'm trying to find a way to exchange
that night off
okay well maybe i could try to be a pest
to this rook
let's go here
yep
and
here it's nice and central
they could still play this move
oh you're going for queen here i see
yeah that makes sense
all right
bishop here
yeah i need some support here
they have a bishop move there as well
i'm not blundering
okay
maybe i should have captured first
oh
i didn't even see that that was a move
so fast
yeah i am busted
yep
this is the the hail mary attack
i could take with check
uh
good game lance and that was a berserk
i like that maneuver
i like that maneuver the queen on d4 was
instructive for me right there
um
i knew it was a big decision to give up
the dark square bishop but i didn't see
that idea to take advantage of the
or to i should say to make use of
uh
what am i trying to say black made
very good use
of the unopposed dark square bishop
of their unopposed dark square bishop
queen on d4
yeah that caused me to
yeah i was uncoordinated
after their queen landed on d4
nice game
okay
now what do we do
okay
um
the baby step it still
here now i'm ready for this
this guy's defended so that's that was
the big idea
let's carry on with it
pawn duo
oh lance by the way is in second
very nice
okay so knight
what do you have in mind i have a dark
square bishop how can i
how can i put my dark square bishop to
use like lance did
now let's see
what about a kick and then here
and then can i can i focus on one square
like this one right here
sure
let's start with this
you know here i go there
i mean
i mean we could have a similar structure
sort of
as to what lance had
but i'm going to uh
and that may be a reasonable uh
option actually in this position it may
be different but i i do like this idea
of knight here as well
with then
maybe kicking the knight and going here
maybe i should take here
because in that game what happened right
the knight went for this little maneuver
[Music]
which is very effective
i'm going to say let's go
uh here and try to have my knight be a
beast
on
c3
this may mean that i have to weaken
my king's side in order to establish
this night
and i may not want to
rush this move
maybe some prep work first
maybe i could still do without actually
playing this move
what's wrong with maybe this and then a
bishop here or a knight here
or a pawn here
that a pawn right there could arrive
uh
at some point i could maybe bring my
rook to life without even moving it
a6
well this knight is close to trapped now
fish up here
and then i could dive in here it's the
only move after f5
knight here
really don't want to play that move
um
i'm going to make this oddball looking
move just kind of
getting off of this diagonal securing
this point
okay now i'm not there actually
so if i go here now there isn't this
move because the rook is not supporting
so i think now is the time to dive in
here
yeah i think so now now is the time
i'm gonna say
maybe maybe i don't even jump what
oh i missed that move
oh
tricky guy
ah i should know better
well that spoils all my fun
i'm gonna take
all this
oh chess is painful you know
all this work
all of this work stay off of a light
square you dummy all this will work to
try and get a knight to c3
and then boom a tacticaroni on d6
intersection square i thought you had to
go backwards
little did i know
i still have dreams
getting a bishop there
you better take me
uh queen hears something
yeah
oh look at this finesser
are you gonna take
where's that bishop going
oh i see what you did there
i'll still go here oh no no no no no
the knight gets to take and then there's
a fork there
maybe i'll miss it
it's a free punk
yeah i'm hurting now
i'm down on time too
oh
man
i was setting the stage for just a
beautiful piece on c3
and one move spoils it that's all it
takes
what's that line
40 good moves i'm not saying those are
good moves but 40 good moves are negated
by one bad move
or in this case one good move by my
opponent there one one nice tactic on d3
is that d3 d6
that's one i want back if you can't
sense it already
oh
okay
it's an e4 e5 battle let's go king's
indian that's what you do
after you lose a game
throw the king's gambit
out there
mm-hmm
that'll show him
oh man
you know it's not the first time that
that
that tactic has
happened to me you know
forgot about it
nice shot
all right what to do here
the bishop out
why not
be a developer
uh-huh
i think i want to castle queenside i
don't know
spent a lot of time on these very
natural looking moves
maybe i go here and then here
let's try this
[Music]
this isn't how you play the king's gamut
all right
oh by the way this isn't work this move
doesn't work
because knight here will hurt me
queen will be kicked from defending this
square
so
maybe i should uh
back off with this guy
to defend here
first
oh
okay
do i really care about the night
arriving here
yeah whatever
i thought about this
all right
clean side it is
queen is close to trapped should
probably have uh
given a second look to that oh no no no
no
tactic isn't even there
or i'm sorry this this night move i have
this kind of stuff happening
all right so the plan here
is to meet
this move
with this
i mean why isn't this working
night here i take and then take the
bishop this move here i go here i'm on
the bishop and on the night
i think they're gonna have to show me
i think it's one of those i have to
watch out for a night check
but
that night i'll
do the job right
all right let's let's see what the story
is
am i missing another trick
maybe
don't hurt me okay is my queen getting
trapped
please say no
oh
okay
setting this up but i could i could go
here first
let's go here i think i could rely upon
this square for a move
now you could chop and then go in for
the exchange but i don't i wouldn't mind
that the minor pieces should be killers
in this position
once more trying to kill me here
um
let's centralize
i'll bring a draw
there that they should have push uh
given it why why am i giving this pawn
up
nobody knows
let's try and
bring this guy to life
just want to get rid of some pieces
gotta take that guy or this one
with check
and it takes bishop let's check
i don't mind having double isolated
pawns okay
putting a lot of pressure on me i don't
like that
i got a3 now
i could maybe even consider capturing
that looks fun
rather do without that
to a rook and a night for the queen
rock
my knight is doing a lot of dancing
and in the end there is a fork on board
a lot of dancing
nice thing is that at the end of all
this i am
well right now i'm centralized
good place to be
soon to be up a full rook
two checks three checks in the position
take towards the center still on the
queen still on the rook
smoke is clearing
this rook is not a contributor
yet
but it should be too late because i'm
taking taking everything essential
things are good
let's see
all right let's take the rook
just take stuff
all right we'll save the night
grab a pond take here next
clean his back in the ball game
go here
let's go hunting
safeguard against any checks
get this pawn
and we're ready to go
let's double up
main two
if rook takes
knight a lot of ways to do it
right
make it simple
all right
give up a rook just to push that pawn
through was the idea okay
how long have i been going at it here
it's too late to keep going
four hours
ah
ah liquid egg product thank you very
much man
for the 1000 bits you add
dude it's way past your bedtime
yeah it is no no it isn't i'm normally
in a night owl
all right
um
let's try c
five i haven't played this in a bit
all right
maybe we try the slippery snake
let's try the slippery snake
yep
and i'll take
yeah so
let's see how aggressive white wants to
be
yay or nay on that okay now we back up
right here right here right here
right here right now
when this move is no longer available
after i back the bishop up so now we get
these moves in
we beat we we be a developer
we continue to develop
and go for a little journey
let's also keep this night out of uh
yeah let's keep the night out of this b5
square
that may have been a move earlier no i
had a check it was only after there
wasn't a check after castles this was
something serious maybe
maybe
let's do this first
i want my knight to be here to watch
over from both of these squares the
night watch is over e5 but
the big difference is that this guy is
free
to view the world
should i dive in here
let's do this
and then maybe here with tempo and then
maybe this
that's getting a little crazy do i want
to do that
how about i just leave them as is
if you want to play this you play it
meanwhile if this knight goes here i do
have b5 also the
usually this clamping down move
against this structure is not available
with this bishop here when normally it's
fiend kettled or on e7
no a5 in this case
this would interfere with the bishop
observing b5 right now i can't do this
maybe
maybe i can in some variations because
the e4 would be undermined
these guys have a couple
responsibilities so it may be overloaded
so now is my time
to get these uh queen side pawns rolling
i mean what what's the plan here here
chop chop chop chop chop
and then you get with this i think i
still i just need to do it this is the
the way forward if it enters something
complicated
oh that's just how it is
yes
that's how it is
okay
we're gonna have a weird imbalance
yupper
and i think i come out ahead after all
this because uh
i got this guy right
okay
i could take that bishop with check and
probably should i like that eventually i
have a
a check against the king on h2
or
do i just take here right now and say
you take me
because i don't want this pawn to get
rolling
um
well my rook's gonna have to
i think my queen's important to have
back here
i'm gonna take
i think that's that is the right thing
to do
and now take here so what's the body
count rook and pawn versus two nights in
bounce
oh i shouldn't fear this move because i
have this this is a strong pose like
lance
posted up there in our game queen right
here
this is a big square what i should be
looking more at the dark squares in the
position
this guy will not control any
so this is a hole this is a whole good
homes
on these two maybe this one as well
okay so you're getting out of that
check
i understand
suppose i go here
and just try to hunt this pawn
and also i am pointing at this square
um
oh what's wrong with this actually
probably in some
some hot water yeah
hmm
oh wait wait wait this move right
maybe i should be looking to attack the
king
do i have tricks over here
flight square
uh
i don't know let's start with this
secure square
i mean i do have a lot of pieces uh
near the king
so flight square
sneak enough light square
maybe i uh
give up that bishop or something
i don't know
oh what about oh actually queen takes
here dummy queen takes stops rook here
hit a queen there
hmm
i'm looking for something against their
king if i can
you know hear a knight on this square
would maybe be the best
maybe i like this as the best flight
square this one here the bishop can
control
this with king here i think is nice
maybe that's the way
it's tough
okay i'm taking here now i have my back
ring covered i'm threatening mate
oh and then i have this maybe
i have this too
[Music]
also there's checks
say
let's get the flight square in there
okay
check
another check
threatening mate
okay
you know
i think it was after that uh imbalance
took place
i emerged the better side but it wasn't
clear
um i had my fears for sure
um
i was concerned quite a bit about my
back rank
is this the one who uh
yeah
the trickerone oh okay maybe we could
get into that same position again
okay
i had black in that game
i don't know maybe we enter that same
position let's see
all right we're going in that direction
so now that i'm doing everything on the
queen side here
okay well it's a different structure
oops
oh
i just dropped the pawn
oh
okay it's a big pawn to give up
it's not going good
all right let's try to do something
aggressive
[Laughter]
another trick
another trick
[Music]
another one i should know better
should know better
all right we're gonna take
i nearly played uh
bishop here
forget
why is this happening
if here i have this threatening the
knight and i can maybe win the pawn
i'm gonna secure stuff yes
nice and secure
um
i don't have this move
um
oh let's
still stick around here
still stick around
be nice to get in the top 20 area
because then you start playing against
these tough guys up here very high rated
good get some good quality games in
all right let's begin
i have a back rank issue
my opponent wouldn't fall for this with
the here here rook here
saying you take my bishop i give mate
and a couple
but knight here rook d2 rook here i have
bishop takes knight
anyhow what will they do
that move
yes
okay
um
flight square
and if so what kind
what color
here that concerns me
here is not working but i could
could threaten that
all right
let's go with this
so multi-purpose
i want to squeeze a little bit more out
of just a
you know
it's a flight square and maybe
i establish a pawn on this square
challenge this
at some point
so now i do have a threat to chop and
chop
chop and then chop on c3
try to get active with my rook now that
i have a flight square
and now is my time i gotta act
fast here it is i am
putting pressure here
uh also if this i could actually capture
and then take here
is my knight going to be given a kick
yes
really have a great square do i what
about this actually
uh here there's that
um i'm gonna say let's go here
this might be the new seventh franc
right
there aren't any white pawns
all right this is the the new second
rank the third rank is is looking pretty
nice
so i am down upon still
but i do have the more active rook so
that should be worth something
i'll see all right the rook is gonna
babysit the night i expect
and uh
time to get this guy rolling
uh let's get here actually i think
they're prepared to go here i think my
rook is better placed on this square
start to poke around at these these
points okay there
all right so suppose i take i probably
need to and if i go here the bishop's
going to have to come back
i still have a
hmm
yeah let's go here
i think before white can do anything
they have to uh let's not lose on time
against this guy again
um
let's get the king over
oh they're getting active like this huh
i'll keep my bishop around
let's go pawn
i'm going to check
get on that diagonal
can't attack this pawn
no no no no no i need this guy around
stop that
i have another passer to work with
now i'm threatening this
okay
hop back down upon early
tough customer
all right fast pairing rb1994
first time playing okay
nice
all right french
defense
we'll try tarash
knight d2
okay
um
yeah let's immediately push
yes
bishop here
knight here
f6 coming
ooh that's surprising okay
so no f6
huh
all right
castle all right how far do i want to
allow that pawn to go
uh have you gone far enough maybe you
have
all right
it's a big square i've given up
to be sure
yep
all right
let's go here
to queen night in disguise
right
and
i mean there is this one square but i
maybe this guy just
sits there for a bit
[Music]
i like this square
yeah let's go here
hmm
so let's see what the intentions are
first of all you're going to castle into
into this are you going to go here wow
it's a big big decision a very big
decision
so i believe they are prepared to go
so first of all let's consider a check
check here bishop here king there
i don't see what the follow-up is i
think
i'm in trouble soon
um
here here here here
here
hmm
[Music]
i'm to say mission accomplished with
provoking g6
let's go here keep my bishop's eyes
opened
yeah they're angling for this square
you got it
all right let's first of all
go here
all right i have to play a little
defense
this is yours and they're ready to go
queen side
for sure
this knight could do some
other stuff
let's get them in the ball game
let's go here
right here is my idea
we're setting up some tricks
sack and then this stuff
okay big decision there
so they're gonna go uncastled in this
game
i guess that's just how it is
all right
let's go here
[Music]
here
this guy is not playing the bishop but
there are some
some knights over here okay so that's
where you're going
to put a little pressure on this knight
we'll drop back
i think
let's go here
i have a square too
let's just defend this
that's secure
um
[Music]
fearful of night here actually
trying to find a way to coordinate
i wanted to guard this square from the
okay
it's that
pick up another one
wow
i can't even stop that pun
hmm
[Laughter]
give me activity for my queen
hope for a perpetual
or me
no not perpetual the queen's there
oh man knight takes b2
knight takes b2
ah okay
strategy strategy strategy
time got the best of me
all righty
um
another one one would like to have back
one would like
okay
let's do a little dance with the knight
green what are you doing as the opponent
let's stay trained on this point
um
oh they're extra fast with contesting
the file i need to move my knight
let's go
this is a move
at some point
[Music]
okay
start with this
in the long term
i have this in my favor
queenside majority
i'm not really sure at what point it
needs to get in the game like what
pieces exactly should be exchanged that
would
best emphasize this positive for me
certainly a king and pawn
i i i would say
with basically every exchange pieces
this
starts to become more of an asset
not to worry about my bishop being
challenged now
so we're having some battle over the
e-file
one rook exchange
maybe nearby
oh here's maybe something i could uh
something i can think about
it's not a draw upper
um
what about this little baby move
with this as an idea okay they're
ignoring this uh this plan
let's do this
not that this is going to be some great
target for me it's short-lived but now i
have
these pawns become a bit more fixed and
so
this night starts to dream of
getting to one of these two
so
i can maybe begin i may i may want to
have one rook exchange
one rook exchanged
or uh
what about this this move is that
something
trying to restrict these guys a little
bit
a bit torn i could maybe maybe go here
first
yeah what's wrong with that
um yeah let's take one baby step
and i'm just prepared to inch my king up
a hair
i'm also controlling e4
so i
eliminate a pivot square
or an inter excuse me an intersection
square
this also has a responsive
black has a responsibility to defend f7
if knight here i think i'm prepared to
take and enter a knight versus bishop
position
i'll soon have to play here
this will be under fire
and i could also do that right now as
well
probably should so out of the line of
fire defense of d4 time to improve the
king
hmm
yeah
it may be angling for this
no no no you can't just yet
because i could win this pawn
ah important detail i thought
i think i can i think i can
yeah they may go after my b-pawn
knight a4
but i could also go hunting after their
b-pawn
and they still have a back rank issue to
sort out
okay
and what's stopping me from getting to
the seventh rank right here right now
nobody
this is going to force
a rook exchange and i have to go here
31 seconds
night there
surprising
here just invites this
no no no back off
oh let's do it
yeah bishop here
and then bishop here
i wanna not i don't want to allow this
move
my rook is
out of control
very very active rook right now
to go
to go defensive
and now it's just a matter of getting my
knight doing something
constructive the king is cut off the
knight is
is completely under control oh i didn't
even consider that as a move let's go
here
knight on c5 should be fantastic hits
the bishop
my bishop is out of play but my knight
is arriving
fast on the scene
look here look here this is a passive
rook this is an active rook let's keep
the active rook
let's hit the rook
to be bigger no here i'm oh no i'm
winning i'm winning i'm on the bishop
yeah they walked into
walked into that one let's just
go all the way back
picking up the pace here
okay
okay
it worked out
a lot of maneuvering
which involves a lot of identifying what
pieces aren't carrying their weight
who can do better who can do better
who can do better raise your hand
my knight was raising his hand at one
point and my bishop
improve those pieces
okay
let's
get this guy
here
now bishop here
don't want to obstruct this pawn too
soon i still have
an idea to maybe
play c4 and then
we've been here before this uh is that
the game i played
no that was a
sicilian
okay
let's begin
it's night here
no better square
all right
castle
clean here
all right
i think i'm gonna take
yeah let's take
and
okay well this knight belongs here for
sure
rook d1
yeah let's let's be very active here
check to win the queen is the
idea also have
no i don't have yeah i mean i do have
that move if i want it if i really want
to get rid of light square bishops i do
have this move
bishop takes i take here
take me take here first and then
recapture
backing up
all that to exchange light square
bishops
feels like i should have something more
like here than here
yeah well actually
like
this move and then
[Music]
i have to be on the lookout for this
this is black's
big square on d4
so if i want to
control that i would think about moving
my knight right now with this here
knight here and this
that's that feels like it's something
too let's let's just be a developer
okay
and uh my idea now is to hop in
hop in
if knight takes i take with the bishop
and i'm a step away from having a light
square bishop exchange i'm also clearing
the way to now control the knight
ctrl d4
still hop in he's hopping in
and
i was prepared to
make this move
extending the scope of their bishop
but i could try to negate it
or they're considering taking here first
that's interesting
that must be the only other move they're
considering yes they went for that
do i have some fancy night move
like i think maybe i do what about
knight here
threatening a fork
pawn takes and then i take like this
i it might be winning
is it that serious uh
move i think it is
yeah also notice the only open file
um
i'm apparently controlling it
and i controlled the key pivot square d8
and i should be keeping this file open
so no no pawn takes in this
case their king position is
a bit iffy okay
probably
double up
how do they fight for this uh
control over you know how do you negate
the rooks
it's tough
okay first of all
let's stop this idea to kick and maybe
go pawn grabbing
my bishop is unprotected
i don't need to stay here defending this
this pivot square the rooks are already
charged up on the d file
you could think about relocating the
bishop somewhere like here
putting pressure on this point
transitioning to an ending a queenless
ending is is fine
i'm gonna try for this
it hit me once
okay they're doing that
let's back off
this guy's having a tough time whoa
they have enough support for that they
had a
yeah they
had up some brain cramp there it happens
keep in mind this is
i mean
this guy could have been playing right
from the beginning you don't have to be
playing right from the beginning
uh i know that from past marathons i've
played quite a few
tried to do one for the whole thing
not even close
to pulling that off
yeah you start your brain starts to do
some weird things
[Laughter]
make some mistakes that you
normally would not be making
how do i want to
play here
let's put the knight on c6 i haven't
i haven't done okay
um
all right i guess we just quickly
transpose
let's let's go here
alrighty
d4 now or maybe never okay right now
oh
they're booked up here is that what's
going on
okay don't go here
speaking of
bad things happening
um
i've already slipped up
here bishop here
castles there's this
do i need to take this knight
oh that can't be right
i feel like i need to though
bishop block yeah
you gotta do this
i'm up a pawn
it does not feel like it though
i need to get castled
take here with the queen
okay
my night ready to be trapped
here here i have this
to watch out for a check and then a
quick rook move here
um and i need to move i need a square
for my knight
f4 is ready to win the night
huh
do i have to
play
f5 is this already busted it feels like
it's already busted
do i have to play c5
oh brother
i got problems to solve and we're at
move 10 shouldn't be like this
but it is
i know
you simply go uncastled
check you just go here see look at how
easy
[Laughter]
[Music]
i got a lot of work cut out for me yes i
understand
but this first
get out of there man
scaring me trying to coordinate on e8
okay now my knight's ready to be scared
for sure
okay queen go back home
i have a nice structure
my king does not like hearing that
though
no not at all
my first aggressive move
fear that night
oh yeah
castle by hand
it shouldn't be that bad oh
it's a nice tempo
about this
let's go here my knight needs this
square
[Music]
okay
some squares here
opponent continues to fly
[Music]
defense
defense let's make an active oh
i'm saying defense i almost lost on time
trying to be sneaky with my queen
trying to get active
she's active
hold up on
right here sen
centralize the night
time gainers need some time gainers
trying to slither on in
okay
i want to take one more
no no no
let's take here
of course you would go for that
all right
what's the story man okay they resigned
whoo
i should have went back into that game i
needed to i need some closure that that
opening was a disaster
that
that did not feel right
at all
okay here's the top dog whoa he's at a
beefy 300
wow
a beefy 300 man
look at this early 97
[Music]
what's the big idea
c4
alrighty
i said this towards the beginning of the
stream this guy is rated 25 50 feet a
has it in the profile
he's a monster
[Music]
feels standard these moves
it's now the time to take
i've played it where i don't take
but let's do it
and do it again here
i think i need to
okay if this is this a move
no because of this
okay this this move here
bishop here bishop here
um
night move
no no no
night move but that okay
so here
yeah let's back off
all right
time to maneuver my bishop
say yeah try to get it active
right here ideally so i mean probably
stop the idea of bishop c4
somehow that's how
um
this feels like a start
i want to leave control this square too
soon
i guess we'll sneak in the flight square
or just move the knight
yeah let's try to play active
have my rooks ideally placed if there's
a
stuff opening up i really these these
are really the squares to
the files to be on c and d
okay
this will sneak in the flight square
okay there's that move now
okay
let's see
rook
this weird position where
if uh
rook takes rook i gotta recapture of
course
and then if uh bishop takes bishop i
could take with the knight to defend the
pawn if i want to do that
but i think they'll go for uh rook takes
rook knight takes and then just take
here right away
no that's a bit surprising
um actually i mean i should i should
take with the rook and counter attack
against this guy
this is the one i want this one i don't
care this this pawn controls this one
and
now i could take here
oh it's important i have this check and
then i could defend my knight
so otherwise they're converging on this
square oh you could still do it though
check and then take here
yes
let's go on the offensive
getting mated
nice trick
yeah nice tactic
struggling on i would have a chance if
there was just one pawn i was down but
here it's
it's gonna be tough
try to be active with my king
try
let's give a check there
in here oh hey
i gotta try and still fight for this
king position oh so much for that
yup getting rocked back
try to break up the pawns
okay
good game hmm
yeah that night on e5 it was strong even
as it got simplified that f7 pawn fallen
nice little trick there at the end too
to win a second pawn
good game that's the pack leader
lance
i wonder if lance is gonna play in the
whole
the whole thing
smiling friend
i should probably not play too much more
i think i'm gonna actually just go
a few more games
gotta get some sleep
all right
uh
let's do something
different
it's fiance
try and do something with this guy
let's castle i was considering this move
actually
uh
okay
i mean after this move
let's see
and just push it on up
right here let's move forward
karmar what's going on thank you very
much for the resub man
tyr
won 11 months in a row now
hello back
so there's this pin i have this in mind
hitting here
i care about that i
care about it
all right let's go here
like my position
okay
here
here
here now okay
probably just take
take with the king
yeah
i don't see an issue here
yet
now let's take
okay and now let's do something active
for once huh
a queen here
coordinated on this square
knight on f4 queen on g5
okay that could be scary
and i'll back off safeguard my king a
little bit
this here should be dangerous even if i
lose this pawn i don't know if i really
care
so much about that this pawn does a good
job restricting these two so even if
this guy is lost
these two
restrict these three so i could try to
stir up trouble elsewhere is what i'm
getting at i i don't have to
you know just babysit this pawn directly
they may be gunning for a queen exchange
i think i like right now this uh idea to
pin
in double pawns and they're they're
allowing that
and this should be excellent for me
bishop on the same color squares as the
pawns a knight that will have a square
on f4
i'd love to have both rooks exchanged
can i make that happen
oh another thing actually
what about gaining a tempo against the
queen first
and is this the correct rook to go with
or this one is this going to be a
problem
no i'll say go here
maybe no maybe maybe i uh i should have
some some strong tactic instead of just
going for a
a double pawns okay they are doing that
that's crazy
unbelievable i can't believe that move
was just played
maybe there wasn't anything better
there's no way this could work
can it
about this and then here
let's leave some gas in the tank here
leave some time
to
try and think through
my night gets here
okay offering a queen exchange
and i want a queen exchange man
oh so if you don't want a queen exchange
you go here what this has an idea
aha
get to maintain my clean position meet
you one threat also
this is secure
right here
and this should now be winning i could
even afford to give this pawn up
so if they stop rook here
i still go here queen takes pawn king
here no good follow-up checks
okay
ooh with that w i got across a hundred
nice
ah
this guy had me on the ropes when we
played
right out of the opening okay let's stay
out of something theoretical maybe
all right
let's see i got the white pieces this
time
alrighty
alright let's give a check
um
let's get that guy playing
keep that bishop
yeah
it'll be a
beast maybe
that move
all right
well
let's take
prepare to feed keto so this pond is
going to live
that's just how it is
should i play this
though
um
what about this move actually
and i have an id of that and also a4
a4
yes
now let's start with this
threatening rook here if knight here oh
this is just that move
okay
all right
here knight there within bishop takes
pawn is going to be strong
maybe i should have played that move
back
i need to keep the queens around
and stay out of this night's reach i
have to still defend here so no queen c1
knight b3 with
with a punch
okay that i do have this move no
hitting the queen and the bishop
that's a mistake
okay i think i might be winning with
just one move now
okay
get rid of that guy
and now
this guy is an absolute killer
no rush
stop this
castle
long term what's this guy doing
clean there
you want this guy
okay
i could open up the center
okay
let's keep going for it let's let's try
to get out the king
on some squares man my bishop and queen
let's go here
i want this one i want this pawn to be
passed
tripled pawns
this guy goes
let's check
let's take the rook get the other rook
invited
to the party here
rook on b1 bishop takes
c6 he has to go here night block
and it resigned
okay
ooh
19th
what's first place or uh you gotta get
to 135 to get page one that's not
happening
you try to get
maybe 11th area i'll be signing off from
this stream
before
i show up on page one
marathon marathon
account created just for this one
this this account already is scaring me
i just
write out the like
certain names just just created maybe
for this tournament
you know like i don't care just
that moment you have to decide what name
to pick
a marathon marathon is the one you come
up with
i don't know man
yup
if i get aggressive here there's that
and then this and it's scary
marathon marathon
oh
okay
let's see
getting squeezed
all right man
i need a square
d5 is the square
yeah why not
i want to play here
that is a bit surprising
must say
that's the first move that makes me feel
like this is an honest account
[Laughter]
i don't know
let's see
marathon marathon
my knight
is not a good piece
maybe this is
my big plan
try and get some space
now let's try
coming under some heavy fire here on the
king side
shoo
still castle
all right bishop
or even a check i have a check available
all right
defense
got a core grip
maybe i could have been a bit more
patient with this move
okay
uh let's go
here
open file
i could put quick pressure on this point
or even try to grant my night access to
this square
time to castle
or time to capture and then play queen
here
if i castle this move concerns me
i'll initiate this exchange
play queen here
i'm definitely ready to recapture with
the bishop this is a must
hopefully i can maintain my queen
position for a bit
and it seems like i will be able to
these are the only night attacks
now i'm ready to castle
and now i'm ready to move my knight to
a better square
it's that bishop up to
may have to try to deflect the bishop um
maybe maybe i have to take here
i mean are they ready to form a battery
and kill me what about bishop here
actually
that's something isn't it
it is a pin it stops queen d3 and any
thought of mating me on the h7
my knight is uh struggling i don't have
to take with a
a bishop on this square anymore i have
some security so my knight is the only
piece not contributing
i have pressure here let's look uh
let's look forward some
um
gotta move gotta move fast
let's take
is that a bad idea
it was a bad idea
oh bishop there i could take here
or i could i could move my knight here
so now i'm threatening to win the queen
oh
oh i'm on the rook and this
i'm winning
oh
what a
what a weird looking night huh
oh
pressure here defend here look for this
next
wow
bishop here
here bishop here i have this
i get to hunt down this pawn
king is cut off
no
tricks no targets on light squares oh
oh man
bishop here i give a check and take the
bishop
improve the king
check
bishop
the bishop
improve the king
what's the simplest way to do it
that okay
the name scared me for sure early on
psychologically
you know you just have it in your head
certain accounts
just by the name and the date created
but that was just a good player
playing fast
all right
um i'm going to say this game coming up
here is the last one
uh yan caesar 74 tier one resub 35 in a
row now
go go jerry you add
all right
maybe playing some tomorrow a little bit
well it's already tomorrow for me it is
3 57 a.m right now
let's see what we get
the grunfeld
or king's indian
now is the moment to decide
gruntfeld
hmm
let's play
now let's do this
all right
it permitted me to play e4
let's
gain some space take a square away from
the knight
going down some
theoretical stuff here
i push
this feels like the
critical continuation
i feel like i may have had this position
before at some point it's here here here
and then both of my pieces are under
fire but i can retreat
and recapture
it's a strong piece on c3 i'm glad
they're thinking at least
maybe this is the first move where it's
uh not theory i don't know
if i took there they were gonna take
here or maybe insert the check first and
then
take their next
anyhow
where are you going are you going
anywhere
the cable box
where are you from
we don't know
all right
um
hmm
right
played here before in this position
right
i think this is the way
what's the body count my opponent's up a
pawn ready to get it back
but it may it may mean that i have to go
uncastled
this take here there's going to be a
check and
i don't know if i want to
crawl up into a ball
i think i'd just have to maybe all right
it's just how it is
yeah we going castled
let's see
if i could get my king to safety
it's not easy
um
[Music]
i don't know how to complete development
in a smooth way
let's try here
here
the knight is pinned for the moment
i'd like a light square bishop exchange
then i feel much more comfortable about
putting my king on g2
this would be the most efficient way to
get my king off of the back rank ooh
check i didn't consider that
i don't have much choice
still in a pin bishop there
yes
all right well let's play active
come over here and defend some squares
if they're gonna mess up my kingside
structure
i have a good bishop
i have some good pieces of my king
my king in this guy over here is what
concerns me most
i'm expecting at some point uh f5 maybe
it's close to happening
because then the rook has access to b2
this is the glue this is what's
currently holding my position together
somewhat oh actually i'm on the night
just forgetting that i'm i'm on the
night here
huh
should i take the night
why not
oh
maybe that's why
[Music]
oh man
yikes
right here i have this
i don't know
still on the bishop
push
and i have a new square for my queen i
don't know can i do without
um
let's go here pass pawn push him right
i'm on the rook
queen here get the queens out
maybe i don't need this guy who cares
about my king right
i don't know what i'm saying
this is the winning move
queen trade
defense
all right
got this
maybe this
why am i going like this says to what
what am i missing
king is a fighter
ah
thanks
perpetual after all this
this is a perpetual
oh it's perpetual what a finish
wow wow
what a game good game man
the cable box
i don't know what this was about
um
oh maybe they mouse
maybe they want to go here and they
grab that pawn instead i
can't make sense of that move
ah
and why why'd i grab this pawn
i don't know
yikes
i maybe there is even a win for black
right around here
check is there some win
is there a winner
no just perpetual from here
so in here but not here and was probably
a win
right around here for black
back
i'm curious about this opening here so
are we following book
it's the move
okay e5 is a move
ella elianov and
nipomnishi
chop
chop we're still following some theory
here
bishop there is still theory
game from 2010 for
or just this one really
black ended up winning
we're still following that game still
following that game
dozen moves in
still following it
not following it
so what was played in this game
i don't want to
i'd have to switch tabs
a new screen would pop up i don't want
to do that
okay
13 moves of theory what was maybe the
next move
it likes bishop b5 as the best move
but black white is definitely struggling
here
okay
queen a4
g takes f3 i took there it's still wow
it's still close
d6
queen c7
shop
and now i just i wanted to get a little
bit more out of this flight square it's
still not the safest flight square as we
observed
that rook
really uh caused me a problem there on
b2 this is the safer one
[Music]
or even uh
h4 depends on how aggressive you want to
be but
yeah this is where it was not good and
you know back to back
not so good moves
okay yeah that's a good one to finish on
that was a fun game
you